[Applause]
oh you can perfect
[Music]
what's up YouTube my name is dopa ziola
Thomas whatever you want to call me we
are here back with another episode of
the dope as usual podcast I am here with
my co-host Marty O'Neal what's up guys I
am Thomas dopasiola whatever you want to
call me this is the dope's usual podcast
I'm here with my co-host Marty O'Neill
what's up guys how you doing this is
another episode it's another week we're
here to help you out get through the
time get through the day kill work
school whatever if you're in the
bathroom hiding watching this shout out
to you you'll have about 30 seconds
where people start looking for you all
right people hit me up all the time and
also be safe
be safe in the car I got another one
last week I said never thought it
happened to me let's just crashed the
car while they're driving
pay attention all right just pay
attention that's all we're asking drive
safe hands ten and two just listen you
don't have to watch just listen watch
when you get home that's what he says
like I look down for just a second we
ran to somebody come on man be safe out
there all right Mr dope's usual podcast
I'm gonna do something real quick that
we uh don't do often enough go follow
our our Instagram all right it's dope's
usual podcast so far Instagram Marty is
fully crushing it booming right now
Marty's crushing it all right he's doing
great thumbnails and Great Clips and
everything's working
it's looking like a real page also
what's our Facebook dope as usual
podcast on Facebook
we never used it we got 25
000 in 28 days 31 yeah we're guys thank
you for all the support on these social
channels each one of our social channels
right now Tick Tock uh the shorts
Facebook Twitter over half a million
we're reaching between half a million
and a million plus Impressions on each
of these channels in the rolling past 28
days and these are all basically new
yeah we don't thank you we used it yeah
so thanks we're one of those podcasts we
explained it have you guys ever been on
Tick Tock or Instagram and go wow this
podcast what is this podcast it's got
four million views on this clip whoa
then you go to their YouTube Code 17 000
views and six months
why it's because they have really good
socials and maybe not a lot of people
are going to the full episodes we're the
opposite we have trash socials until
recently really fun episodes and people
flock that's why our watch time was what
69 million hours this month
where's the [__] come on
let's go 69 million watch time hours
get out of here that's ridiculous
preposterone that's insane considering
what we're up against on YouTube right
now yeah that's on YouTube on the
platform that we're Shadow banned from
could you imagine if we weren't
yeah thank you and we're not going to
complain about it again
we're done complaining about YouTube we
thank you guys for supporting us and
most of all shout out to Spotify for
brand Brandon well not branded back
we're official partners with Spotify
we're talking about some speaking stuff
I'm not sure if we're gonna do it
Spotify is all in guys for the next
three months if you're on Spotify
there's a real good chance you're going
to be seeing dope as usual banners on
the home page yeah
they're actually tutorials and features
about the show to start growing us on a
platform that actually wants us thank
you Spotify thank you for everyone out
there helping me and Marty just hey do
what you're doing
just do what you're doing like we will
and we're asking them right now guys
give us premieres give us like comments
comments let us grow this community on
Spotify so we can just be explicit in
ourselves and do our thing so Spotify
does that you can thank the show yes
well actually you could thank Marty
because he's the one that keeps asking
for it premieres comments what would you
tell them just watch just let us be the
guinea pigs see what it does we're gonna
spike it I'm excited we're just having
fun over here man it feels good it does
it feels really great it reminded me
because you know just having to deal
with malcol had put everything on pause
and it just reminded me how much I love
doing this stuff and as I'm getting
ready to put out this course it just
reignited my passion for making social
media content it's it's all the skills
wrapped up in one because Photoshop
skills The Branding skills it's the
video editing I'm telling you it's like
it's those ones you're picking just go
follow our Instagram and our Tick Tock
and Facebook because Marty is crushing
it right now there's just
so much traffic coming in from these
clips and some of these clips are from
an episode a year ago yeah
exactly we have a lot of new fans that
we didn't our socials we never touched
and we're like yo let's do it and now
people are like what is this show
exactly yeah dude go watch it we've been
around for for like a little over two
years come come hang out with us yeah
guys our last episode legendary young
and Jeezy it got Shadow banned they'd
YouTube did not like the trappy elements
of us talking the entrepreneurial
qualities of a Trap God apparently but
he wasn't even talking drugs
he's talking entrepreneurial get your
real estate license this is what I do in
the morning I drink tea and it was one
of my favorite episodes of all time and
they age restricted the second and went
off I know we say we won't complain but
they buried the episode the second it
came out and I was expecting YouTube to
love that one we talked about positivity
he didn't even smoke
you only do so much but
Spotify I think the numbers are higher
than the YouTube numbers
not to mention we went viral again off
that thank you for everybody supporting
that we're talking complex HOT97
[__] Vlad TV all kinds magazine
full articles and we're actually getting
the credit now appearing on dope as
usual podcast with the [__] embedded yes
not like they did US filthy on that ddg
yeah
from chips looking like Eric Estrada
yeah yeah well you know that's all they
did is my little circle of my face
that's funny and it went everywhere yeah
that was on Facebook 130 million views
on Facebook
yeah not on our Channel though on
someone else's Channel
it's funny how they do that it must be
nice to just sit around and just pick
people's [__] and just post it
they didn't credit us which sucks but
it's okay
um hip-hop DX everybody show love
everybody everybody not even reposted
they did articles on the episode yeah
come on hours after it came out and
shout out to Jeezy he posted up two of
our Clips on his timeline [__] out of it
epic thank you so much for that like
we not a lot of guests
like promote the episode
surprisingly like everything I ever do
like please give me the breakdown give
me the things I'll post it all I want
your episode to do great like that's the
point of why I came not a lot of guests
do that for us which is very kind of
it's kind of disappointing but it's okay
I think Jeezy had the tightest biggest
team we've had of anybody yeah like six
fools here they were all like on point
there was some presidential [__] the way
they were [__] moving it was but they
also hit like probably eight interviews
that day instead four more after us they
did three this morning I think he would
have puffed that [__] he was scared
of that Jay when you gave it to him I
think he would have puffed it though if
he didn't have so many more God damn it
before after us yeah that's a lot man
that's a lot
um the episode was insanely cool
what a sick episode uh congrats to our
winner of the giveaway too getting that
one of one [__] Smack DVD thank
you thank you and also I think we're
gonna slow down on the giveaways on
YouTube doesn't like it YouTube
once again I'm sorry for talking about
again we have an agent in Shadow Man and
buried the past four episodes
since we implemented the giveaway and
the thing is on dope is your channel
four years ago I did one giveaway first
when I ever did they deleted the entire
video off my channel 30 seconds after I
premiered actually it was premiering and
it just turned off went black screen and
everybody in chat like what I thought
you got to leave it's before I ever got
deleted YouTube doesn't like giveaways
only if you're doing stupid [__]
apparently but
we're gonna do it on Instagram so once
again boom over the screen dope as usual
podcast as this is coming out we'll post
another flyer we'll do another giveaway
we're gonna do a giveaway tomorrow be
easier to do it on Instagram come on
Instagram's so much easier tag a homie
we have to transfer back to YouTube just
you know help us out go watch the
channel because we're getting really
restricted and it helps when you you
know you're active on it doing all kinds
of [__] on until I did something the
other day share this to your store get a
follow back I want the page to be
following when the real fans of the show
so we're filming following probably like
four or five hundred of the fans now
800. yeah like if you guys think that's
cool if you want us checking out your
page and being like but also on the page
if I go in there and there's not one
post on there I might probably not
follow it because we're following a
ghost account not doing that because
then it looks like we're just following
Bots and we bought our followers and our
engagement which we don't even know how
to do so don't ever see some [__]
like that I see uh
you see those rappers 700 000 likes 15
comments I don't know if we'll spend
good 280 to buy that to buy those likes
on that post that [__] your page over
time oh it makes your page look bad
comedian some of the comedians that I
worked with did that early on and it
[__] their page over because then it
screws the ratio of your engagement
because this is what people don't
understand about how these platforms
work now like whether it's YouTube or
Instagram or whatever it's judging your
post and then it's going to show it to
however many people it wants based on
its Judgment of your post yeah it's not
yo 900 000 likes bro nobody wants
anyone that's tricky we've had people
try to trick us on the podcast with [__]
like that we've had I won't say who but
we've had a couple artists hit us up
flood our comments with their fans but
I'm I'm a social media that's my brain I
told I let Marty know on some of this
I can go through your page and know if
you bought followers I can tell if you
bought likes or engagement
and I don't even know how to buy it and
I can tell you when it's fake off the
bat I see a lot of huge rappers I go who
is this fool oh he's a guy with that
song was like wow a little baby I'm not
saying it's one of those rappers
I'll go on the page and go hmm
400 comments in a row which is Hearts
different people just Hearts let me
click a pay oh yeah no posts
all right let me click this page oh wow
one post click this page oh posted six
years ago
okay so you're buying fake engagement
that's cool I guess I saw someone win an
award in the Cannabis community
with fake engagement I told everybody
that fool would be gone and forgotten in
three months for one a year or like a a
big award like who who is that never
heard of the man in my life
now he's on a magazine cover who's his
dad
who's his dad who paid for this and then
what happened two months later found out
full doesn't even smoke weed kicked out
of the community and like I didn't say a
word I'll never say a word until it's
right here yeah I just
I see it online and go that's why you
never see me hang out with people in the
community I go
not everyone just saying there's some
that's like every time you see this
I'm not chilling with you
well you met a pretty cool rapper in the
community over the weekend right
out in Vegas oh random guys last Friday
let's go through it let's light a joints
yes please real quick shout out to cbx
this is cush mountains
brand new batch right off the plant or
not right of the plant but yeah fresh
but the only thing is it was still a
little fresh so I burped it what does
that mean here's a jar of mason jar
okay pop it let it breathe for an hour
oh
do it over again
imagining him it's like burping a baby
it's like oh okay tending to it that's
the that's what you're tending okay over
and over and over all right I got this
ZIP and a half of of
my [__] cush mountains right uh-huh
gave it to me two weeks ago I haven't
smoked a smidge of it yet because I've
been burping it waiting for it to crisp
and getting a little tighter and get
stinkier it smells like an open can of
tuna now
I've been having this cbx on Deck it's
hard to go back to regular weed I know
weed's good there it is there it is for
you
all right tannins the Cannons scare
regular humans are easy yeah he's one of
the normal I was going to make a
highlight reel that everybody's
reactions to the show yeah was this a
[__] what is this how many people
have done that
these are not these are not even Story
Time joints no these are smediums these
are mediums no they really are these are
these are like uh I'm an eighth grade
size are you gonna make pre-rolls when
you do the push trees weed yeah like the
last time oh [__] so you can smoke them
with me while we do Story Time
a lot coming
all right oh so last week I went to Las
Vegas to do Champs it's a you know for
the dopa shop
boring event but
the next day Friday we were supposed to
have the Mexican
OT come on the show can you gotta really
set the context though how crazy it was
with our bookings and your traveling and
[__] because it wasn't only him that we
were oh okay so look it
we're trying to it's Thursday I'm
supposed to leave Las Vegas Friday
morning and I say no no no because Rosie
has a race on Sunday in San Francisco I
have to come back from Vegas Thursday
night wake up Friday morning go straight
to film two podcasts that we're supposed
to have lined up after the two podcasts
drive to Merced fall asleep wake up go
to Rosie's sister's baby shower or baby
uh gender reveal
across the lake
literally across the lake in Merced
Yosemite lake is my dad's the first time
ever doing a family reunion so I hit I
killed two birds of one stone went to
Merced
and then as soon as we're done with the
parties we have to drive straight to San
Francisco go to Rosie has to go to sleep
just wake up by one or two in the
morning and she's gonna do her Marathon
[__] insane my whole last week was
like this
Clockwork
right I was just here here here here
here here here here
so we're in San Francisco boom
Thursday I'm at uh Champs
and Mario's like yo Mexican OT confirm
he can do it tomorrow like oh yeah let's
get it and then our booking age goes
also Benny The Butcher says he could do
tomorrow night
I'm like are you [__] kidding me
we're gonna have Mexico tea in the
morning better than the butcher at night
and then we'll drive straight to Merced
on him I'll get on drugs basically
because I'm so high
and what happened Mexico T couldn't make
it because he had a different more
interviews it just didn't work out
Thursday at 10 minutes after we're like
he's booked for tomorrow I'm like oh
hell yeah
I look up because I'm waiting for food
at Champs to look up and I see Mexico
tea walking into the building like for
real and I walk up to him like yo what's
up man he's like oh hey how you doing
you know like normal
kind of weird hey what's up bro because
y'all know me you know I walk up to him
like hey what's up dude hey I'm a
[__] fan uh I'm I was like I'm the
guy you're supposed to do we have a
podcast we're gonna do he's like oh in
LA tomorrow right I go yeah yeah that's
me because random I know it is random
and his Road manager looks at me goes
dope is Yola what the hell and he like
he's a fan right the best I was like
good [__] I was like don't worry I'll
see you tomorrow Baba you know do the
whole thank you very much nice to meet
you I'll see you tomorrow he's got fans
already coming at him I'm like I'm doing
my thing over here do your thing I'm I
know what it's like to walk through
places and you have fans like it's hard
to conversate with fools when you try to
conversate with fans
so my don't trip blah blah drive back
Mexico team couldn't make it totally
okay because I was so [__] tired
I was drinking I had bags under my eyes
from not sleeping and we drove straight
back and well we're in this printer van
I was just dabbing the whole time it was
[__] awesome I was watching movies
and dabbing and smoking the whole time
it was great
um anyway Benny's butcher couldn't make
it either so totally cool Friday go
straight to uh Merced
sleep in the morning due to Rosie's
sister genderville um our niece is
having a girl
then I go across
the lake
and then go to my family reunion right
meet some family I've never met in my
entire life and they're my blood
relatives never met them they live in
Merced never met him
regular Mexican people
regular people
Mexican or not I don't matter I'm saying
like regular ass people from Mercedes
cool
so from there
drive to San Francisco Rosie has to go
to sleep
do a race our race uh boom over the
screen what a view we get this hotel
room with the dopest few I've ever seen
in San Francisco real quick if you live
in Frisco get out
just go just leave it's Armageddon over
there there ain't no money coming in
ain't no money coming out there's only
people walking around on drugs just
sleeping I went downtown there was no
one out I went to hate Street there was
no one and there was a few skaters
that was it
I felt sad Frisco is a dead City there
is nothing left it's insane there's no I
didn't bring my cars because I was like
I don't want my windows broken out I
know for a fact they're going to get
broken out so I paid for the expense of
La I was like nah
underneath your [__] I want it's a
rental car I run it around I just want
to deal with it oh you're not even
talking about the Maybach I was gone I
was like I'm not even risking bringing
this damn car down there
and I got it right on I was still
worried for the rental San Francisco is
supposed to be one of our best cities it
used to be the coolest place ever as a
kid like yo Full House
so when you were a kid it was clean and
nice though it wasn't always clean but
it was it was life it wasn't so [__]
sex I was right on the pier and there
was 30 people outside
to be packed
come on bro it was it was sad it was sad
but anyway Rosie did the race crushed it
did 45 minutes faster than she did last
time wow yeah her and Sammy crushed it
as
I'm waiting there
listen to this
what's your marathon is
vaguely 249 Ultra marathons are 249
miles
249 249 miles
what do you mean Ultra marathons are
like two days long the 249 mile race
249 I thought there were a hundred
oh no maybe I'm thinking the ultra
marathons
yeah I think it's what they said
Ultraman I gotta look it up it might be
the hundred but the one I'm thinking is
damagus it's 240. okay yeah yeah I've
heard I mean that I'm sorry that [__]
the idea of 240 miles is [__] insane
you know what it might be crazy then huh
let's just do a let's just say it was
the 100 mile race it's the ultra
marathon that they did
I heard them announce the man's name and
goes he's actually been running since
the I think was it Friday
it was Sunday
the guy did an ultra marathon and
Forrest gumped it and kept running into
Rosie's Marathon oh my God and finished
before they got there
ultra marathon how much is it oh that
one's only 52. oh so Frisco's Ultra
marathons way shorter
I don't know how that works you know
that makes more sense I'm like yo he ran
a [__] ultra marathon and just kept
it going
so anyway that man uh uh
ran 78 miles that night
I watched him run by and they were like
so and so completing the marathon after
finishing the ultra last night what did
you say
oh bro
that's what I heard
I've been slacking on my [__] ever since
the marathon dudes go ahead just get
Beth I'm about to that's what's insane
bro don't just Merit I told Rosie how am
I gonna do this for I asked her oh it's
the first time she's kind of hurt now
you know after the last La one she
trained with a trainer the next morning
yeah this one her ankles swole
both of her ankles and her feet got
swollen but the hill there's two mile
incline on one part oh God two miles
straight up she said ugh anyway that's
what I did last week let's smoke this
joint
Mario's bust into this uh these notes
guys
so about Mexican OT and Benny The
Butcher inbound episodes at some point
in the near future E40 coming very soon
fluffy coming very soon Cheech Marine
coming very soon all asking us what's
United States
E40 hit us up
no I hit him up oh damn I just saw the
DM from him
that was it oh I didn't see the top I
commented and then he oh that's what
yeah guys if you see us out in the wild
commenting on anybody's page and
Instagram go ahead and below that
comment up I had someone text me hey I
saw you I won't say what rapper I was
like I never said that like bro I saw
your comment no you didn't I never
texted I never commented that and he
sent me a screenshot oh that was Marty
bro that was me I was like oh what are
you talking about yeah put words in my
mouth whatever said that [__] that's a
great example though I hit him up right
in the comment he DM me right back with
his booking agent let's go let's do it
let me 40. let's go I'm excited for that
that's the real power how we need to
come together as a team oh for real you
guys got Steelo brib on here a buncher
bunch of [__] people bunch of people
you guys got on here come on not to
mention the dude we were supposed to
have on this week
we did that major post too that got like
10 000 likes [__]
flight reacts oh that was supposed to be
this it's yesterday yeah yeah we're
having flat reacts on very soon guys all
right he doesn't do very many interviews
so it took some convincing
and also like
watch one episode you think I'm gonna
sit here and Grill you have a bad
judgment he was he was one he was he's
open he's down yeah he's down come on
he's down trying to make that happen
guys because I know a lot of people like
flight reacts a lot of my brothers they
all watch him so
we're getting on him um
got a lot of guests coming guys but this
this is just we had to break it up this
is just us I got some joints rolled I'm
on my I'm on my [__] and I'll get into
that in a minute but I want to break
something down something very near and
dear to my heart Adam Sandler movies
I love him you guys know that I love all
Adam Sandler movies
I'm about to break one down and this
happened in the hotel in San Francisco I
was dabbing and I heard someone go
wait
it's probably the 600 time I watched
this movie how come I never thought
about
you ready I'm gonna go full detail and
I'm actually gonna bring out my phone
because I wrote extensive paragraphs
oh [__] this is this is a first I was
pissed
and then I talked to my sister and she
disagreed with me and I was like you
know what you just want to disagree with
me because I'm right is she as much of a
like a cable guy Style movie person is
you or my sister remembers as much as I
do she has a baby just up wide but
sometimes it's not right okay
can I say I played Ace Ranchero for cam
for the first time he loved it he was he
cracked dying part one or two one and
now he does the butt thing yeah he's
talking with his butt cheeks oh my God
there's some parts in that [__] movie
I had like fast forward through oh yeah
one pair of dog my mom when I first
watched she goes Turn Around what the
hell what the heck I remember my mom
said and I go I always disappeared
standing I couldn't find the remote and
[__] one of those
that's the part my mom was
yo mom we just watched Reservoir Dogs
come on sorry agent here is a little too
much they man got murdered in front of
me come on man he hit somebody with a
well placed like they said something and
Ace hit him with a you're ugly cam was
like oh I kind of want to watch it now
it's been a minute I just remember the
monkey the monkey falling it hurt my
heart when I was a kid in part two
what a good movie Dan Marino let's go
there's a 90 90s is great I don't
respect how they stole the whole
storyline from the bills and gave it to
them I didn't know of them that was real
that's some [__] [__] all right I
didn't know they took our losses and
made fun of them didn't want to hurt us
anymore so they blamed it on the
Dolphins
they just took their heart away from you
if he's probably a Bills fan that wrote
him like no it's not the Bill's Dolphins
Ace Ventura is getting canceled for sure
in this day and age that end scene
everything very Finkel everything oh God
come on man and everybody's just
what a movie
uh
um
I'm about to go in about to go hard
we've done 50 First Dates I was just
watching winning singer and it hit my
head are you guys ready
I'm gonna spit some hard cold facts at
you leave it in the comments if you
agree and if you disagree don't put in
the comments gonna come after you
because be logical you ready
actually I'm not gonna come after you
I'm just kidding
Wedding Singer
I'm gonna look a lot this way okay but
just here we go
Julia Ghoulia is a hoe
Drew Barrymore in that movie
is a hoe are you ready
real quick movie breakdowns here we go
she has no idea that Glenn her fiance is
cheating on her she has no idea
they don't even tell her in the movie
so she's doing all of these things
with the faithful
Beyonce
right
Robbie gets dumped
he starts liking this girl at work right
she's been with this guy for a long they
don't say how long but it's been years
she's been with Glenn right
she meets this guy at work
she meets a guy at work and goes hey I
kind of like this guy but we're friends
come hang out with me and help me with
my wedding stuff you know all right cool
with you friend then she does the whole
makeout scene which is like what is the
kiss gonna be like she kisses Adam
Sandler Drew Barrymore kisses Adam
Sandler in the movie inside of the house
that Glenn probably plays for
she's a waitress on weekends at weddings
there's no way she's paying her rent and
living and has that car and pays rent
and
Glenn is paying for her stuff
so while she kisses Robbie that scene
remember oh my God it was magical then
Glenn walks in
and Robbie I just kissed her I just gave
her the jacket remember they lied about
it and her friend covered ho again
also [__] friend
he was bringing her a CD player it's a
new invention so we want to play a
record no it plays CDs Collette is a
little inconsiderate he was bringing her
a brand new invention to the house he
pays for in the middle of the day and
she was just making out with some guy
from work
ho continue
she does all of this stuff all the
wedding planning all of this stuff
falling in love with Robbie while Glenn
is at work
gotta keep putting that out there he's
at work yes he's cheating on her after
work long hours
yeah that was some Jack Nicholson sound
right there that was crazy anyway she
doesn't know he's cheating she just
thinks he's working his ass off and
she's over here making out with this
dude following all these plans falling
in love with the guy boom
ready fast forward
Robbie gets super drunk right she's in
her wedding dress and the only way she
gets happy when she says Mrs Glenn or
Mrs Robbie Hart she's crying when she's
talking about Glenn is just
for all she knows he's just the same
nice guy that's been taking care of her
for years all right here we go that's
where it gets real bad
Robbie gets all drunk his girlfriend you
know consoles him and wakes up and he's
like what the hell are you doing here
remember she answers the door Julia Drew
Barrymore that morning leaves her house
and goes Glenn don't want to marry you
I'm gonna go tell Robbie I love him and
we're gonna have to separate
goes to Robbie's house all the way all
the while what a loser Robbie I love him
but what a [__] loser he only tried
to get a job at the bank because Julia
thought money would help he was never
going to live his sister's house ever he
works once a week
loser he only sings at weddings loser
like he doesn't care you don't care at
all
Drew Barrymore drew that goes up knocks
and Robbie Adam Sandler's ex-girlfriend
answers and she's like
she thought butt hurt remember and then
she closed the door and she leaves what
does she do she goes home smacks Clan
remember she wakes him up hey hey let's
go get married no let's get married
right now and he's like yeah let's go
in her head she left Glenn went to go
say Robbie I love you oh I'm not
priority anymore and your girlfriend's
back in the picture
don't love you anymore I'm gonna marry
Glenn
real quick that happened
just real quick I know the movie's like
all romantic that's exactly what that
[__] did
right she's like no let's Skate off to
to Vegas I don't love Robbie anymore
because you know I'm not priority and
his girlfriend's there even though I'm
[__] about to get married next week
[__] hoe
all right ready
that day she's like [__] Glenn I'm going
with Robbie Robbie does obviously he
didn't even know she was there you guys
seen the movie
then they get on the plane and hold on
before they get on the plane he's like
hey do you like Flock of Seagulls oh we
only have one I know this movie so well
we only have one seatings in first class
and he looks at his friend and goes can
I borrow your credit card your friend
says you're gonna pay me back right
and what does Robbie say no but if you
don't tell everybody we said at the bar
he's just sitting there blackmailing his
homie for money
so he can go break up a [__] marriage
only Robbie knows Glenn's a cheater
then he writes a [__] song and goes you
know what while I'm in this first class
ticket my friend paid for
I'm gonna sing a song oh my God they're
on the plane I'm gonna go play a song
and here we go
Julie is on the planet gonna go get
married to this man
he goes to the bathroom he's gone for 14
seconds
Robbie Adam Sandler comes in and sings
her a song
and she's like you know what I don't
want to marry you anymore I'm going to
marry this guy flip-flopping ass [__]
then Billy Idol and the big biker
assault Glenn stick him in the bathroom
and lock him in during a flight and
everybody's cheering
one lawyer on that plane this movie
doesn't work
that's kidnap that's it you're holding
this man in the bathroom also they kiss
each other right on the plane what
happens after that there's a whole
flight to Vegas
is Robbie just gonna like take Glenn's
seat
and Glenn takes the first class or does
Glenn just sit in the bathroom for the
rest of the flight because it's
embarrassing
what happened on that flight also also
on the flight Julia's like hey Glenn
I've never seen the bright lights of
Vegas he's like well Jules I'm huge I'm
a full grown man when that car comes by
it cracks my elbows
it and like okay but he's inconsiderate
he should have switched with her I get
it he should switch it there and then
Rosie goes it's daytime
they leave to Vegas in the early morning
where in the country does it take until
night time to see the bright lights of
Vegas bitching Casino lights it's
daytime
and then at the end these two lose their
[__] just get married who paid for
the wedding
they're both broke as [__] they both
work once a week
they only work at weekends weddings
she's a waitress he's a singer who pay
for that [__] wedding serious might
get paid huh wedding singers might be
getting paid no that was the whole movie
he barely made any money he got paid in
meatballs
so I have money I keep I have a little I
keep it in the jar on top of my
refrigerator my sister's basement I'd
like to put more in that jar that's
where you come in that's what he said to
Kevin Nealon he's broke
the reason you try to get the bank job
because he's like I can't compete with
glenny's he's making money I should make
money he only made money to try to keep
up with some dude
in the end of this movie you gotta be
honest
she's a hoe and and and you know
Robbie's a [__] loser she a bigger
hoe than Jenny though
no Jenny Jenny try to get for his AIDS
that's what I thought you might say yeah
she tried to give him a long lifelong
disease Julie just wanted to
[__] hop around the neighborhood
[__]
sorry that's my breakdown to The Wedding
Singer
all right man that [__] was [__]
passionate it's true though only Robbie
knows he's a cheater
so Julia is doing all this to her really
good boyfriend that just might be a
little inconsiderate
please don't puke in my car he's got a
brand new ass whip after the club please
don't puke in the car that's what he
said to her when she comes up yeah he's
inconsiderate
but [__] don't throw up in the car get
you a taxi
come on man all of these things are
reasonable I would definitely let Rosie
throw up in the car I don't care
but Clinton considerate
that's it Glenn the inconsiderate man
that pays for everything is what they
should have called Wedding Singer or
home wrecker I hope Adam Sandler sees
this phone oh I love it's still one of
my favorite movies of all time I love
The Wedding Singer I've watched it uh
six seven hundred times
this week is the first time I ever
thought like wait
I bet you're engaged
you made out with him two seconds later
your boyfriend walks in you just
and her friend covered for her
[__] hoe Glenn leaves room then they
start talking about the kiss you are a
[__] owl done
that's my breakdown of The Wedding
Singer
God damn I've never come with notes like
that before I was like well thought out
sorry that I I had to go in on that one
because
I'm right
I'm only thinking in logical and factual
statements
I am right phaser and got you yeah no
that's that's true though like it's
factual if you disagree I would like to
hear your argument my sisters was
Blended piece of [__]
[__] [__] Julia don't know that
yeah he's a piece of [__] but she don't
know so what's the ammunition for her to
do what she did oh done let's move on
the next topic anyway Marty
ah break it down I'm feeling pretty
[__] comfortable in this shirt
new post trees drop boy that's that
Winery tea that looks like you just go
to the to Olive Garden on a date all
right and this one you can't see the
back will flash over the screen the back
of this shirt is wild
it's bright it's sick as hell actually
what was the inspiration going into that
one
I don't remember but the whole drop
we've done so many different variations
of everything over this one was
different it looked like crumbled yeah
and then we took the crumble off and
that looks better this is the pocket tea
we had to sew these pockets they don't
make three X's so all the three X's we
had them hand make and uh it's okay but
the embroidery on the front we did a
drop yesterday the drop dropped
yesterday
and we have sold out of a lot of almost
we've sold out of a lot of sizes I
didn't think it was going to happen that
much
bigger shop all the time
has to be by far right monetary wise
yeah I mean like items no this is only
eight items the next drop is 17 items
gotcha 17 the full tracksuits pants
jackets skateboard actually the
skateboards I'll show you guys the
skateboard real quick
show you guys this skateboard real fast
sorry
um I got it cold let's go
so yeah push tree is back in full effect
with the oh harder than ever dude yes
smashing now it's a 25 piece collection
dropping
oh dude it's going harder than ever I'm
so sorry guys I'm on my phone on the
[__] show and [__] sorry
oh did I show you this uh I guess my
stepdad's not my old step dad's not in
prison forever he got out oh no got
arrested again my mom was surfing the
internet can I show you this man's face
now sure oh oh my God no no no see his
face
okay kind of almost brought it to your
mind how bad it is because I mean I love
this fool so this is a current Day
picture I've never seen this is a
current picture now imagine this man in
your cell
with the [__] shiv
just rocked out like uh American History
X narrow Norton like he's a buff ass
fool look at him now and look how evil
now when you talk now the stories will
make sense you're like that they were
scared of your stepdad like yeah that
full I know yeah I remember you sir
walked away remember all that [__] look
how [__] evil this guy looks now oh
my God oh my God look at those eyes
Marty that's my step dad man raise me
look how [__] evil you bite your neck
off it looks like he'd be next to evil
dude in the dictionary like he looks
like a logo of like
personify it's sad though because he's
still using I can see he's got no teeth
now you can see it see it I was bottom
reaches almost his nose that means his
teeth are gone now
is that his resting face like did he
always let it snow Flanders he was like
he's always like look goofy nice this is
just he got out this is just 20 years of
not with my mom
just 20 years of bad nights
the shit's sad dude
look at this wow I wish a couple months
ago I wish the fans could see this
bro it's so bad like look at the [__]
and he looks sad though yeah of course
he looks sad he's not even look he's not
really evil he just looks sad dude
so he's in for good now or I don't know
I'd even ask but that shit's wild oh
Sean he's skateboarding all depressed
had to be weird to see that dude I
couldn't believe when I saw my mom said
to me like what is that oh my God and
then dude I saw him on my other homies
he's been in all the story times I told
you one of my friends that used to not
do drugs now he does drugs now he lives
outside
I'm gonna tell you something right now
this was my homie in high school I'll
tell you his name after
we're the same age I just want to say
that before I show you this picture and
when I talk about my friends live
outside I'm not sitting here trying to
like just pulls this line for views and
[__] my friends live outside I haven't
seen this guy in years I'll show you
this picture
he was the pretty kid he was the kid
that looked like scarface's homie Manolo
we always compared him to that in high
school like fool you lucky bastard
[__] ass tan tall pretty [__]
look at my homie right now look at this
man
I found his page he just takes pictures
in different bathrooms and places that
he think he's just staying in
looks like he's might be having a ride
smiling though yeah smiling
but that right there tells me
yeah it's a lot of long nights yeah it's
a lot of sleeping outside that's a lot
of weather effects that's like weather
like living outside yeah literally it's
like a mountain man but he lives in the
city
um
yeah you can see like his skin is like
yeah it's bad it's sad I saw a video on
Worldstar the other day of a 19 year old
that was like by the pictures all right
clearly in really bad shape but it
really was just so [__] horrible
because he was like showing an ABS house
on his finger oh I've seen that dude and
then he starts showing how it's taking
things are falling apart and the dude
that's filming like starts crying like
bro we got to get you to a hospital oh
that's horrible damn where's this
picture I'm so sorry guys one thing I'm
grateful for like [__] might be [__]
up back you know I'm so sorry but at
least none of my friends are really
going through [__] like that it's weird
to see it it's so odd it's so odd to see
like my phone and then all I think about
is the kid version of that I think about
nothing else and when I see Tweakers
like Dan I've hold a kid one day
sorry I'm gonna look for five more
seconds and give up because this is
taking too long on my phone
now speaking of which I just want to
send a shout out because I was
the legendary uh legendary figure out a
buffalo Claire passed away oh the lady
you might know Claire from the legendary
Griselda albums if you're from Buffalo
[__] hit by a car right yeah that's
that's kind of why I wanted to bring it
up I mean what a I mean it's kind of an
interesting life like everybody stop her
name is crackhead Claire this is some
this is somebody else's page
Someone Named It crack that's terrible
that's [__] up I only brought that up
because it kind of shows like pictures
of like what she you know used to look
like and stuff like that but she looks
that a body picture she smiled it yeah
she she definitely looks you know but uh
what first of all what an iconic photo
do you just have that Vision to use that
[__] like as the album cover
I don't know there's a lot of debate on
like were they exploiting her is that
just great photography great photography
I agree especially if she agrees to be
on the show first day I'm sure I feel
like a personifies buffalo
but um
the way that that I actually was just
reading they're like trying they they're
trying somebody in the case of her dying
because what happened was oh yeah uh a
dude was in a car chasing somebody or
something like that he's shooting at a
guy and chasing him and the guy crashes
and hits into her and she dies yeah it's
not really his fault he's almost he's
trying to escape death yeah and cause
death I get that but he's actually
getting shot at it during the shooting
is the one being charged oh good okay he
should be getting charged for that I
totally agree with that dude or wild at
least not to do that hit her like bro
that's like trying to get away from a a
dog and you accidentally knock somebody
into oncoming traffic he's like bro it
was a freak accident I swear to God so I
think he was gonna kill me I didn't see
you
but like it's like yo the family member
don't give a [__]
they you killed their family members I
get it I get it that's sad
crazy ass couldn't find the skateboard
so I just asked for it sorry guys that
was a rant this is not even a podcast
I'm just having a conversation playing
on my phone looking for pictures my bad
guys Jesus yeah but uh
uh that's [__] up recipes and shout
out to everybody affected by that it's
just something that's sad yeah April
knew her and [__] oh really yeah oh
we're only one thing in how long we've
been here 40 minutes oh my God
uh you know what let's start let's go
into some sometimes guys all right look
it I'm gonna ride it out I want to start
doing this I want to go to the open mic
thing or at least just go do one just do
something I think I'm gonna I'm gonna
start let's see how it's time and I'm
comfortable we did Ted Talk nothing else
more stressful than that [__] so I'm
ready all right I'm I'm not gonna get
canceled because you only get canceled
if you care
but some of the [__] I'm gonna say
it's gonna be bad and then I'll start
here
I will say one thing but I think it's
funny
boom
I think there should be
um ready
what did we call it
oh that was that's the next one that's
the next I'm gonna do the the citizen
here we go I think we should do a game
show
and remember before I say this I am
kidding I'm saying it because it's so
stupid that would be like it's a bit
what if there was a game show
where we got racist white men
and had them fist fight illegal aliens
and here's the base
the illegal alien no matter what country
they're from
I don't care whatever race you want it
to be in your head is your is what race
it is okay
racist white man fighting illegal alien
if the legal alien wins he gets
citizenship and some money
if the racist white man wins he gets a
mill
but if the racist white man loses he has
to leave America forever
you [__] you got that loaded up could
you imagine
yes yes I love this idea and as I was
telling somebody I was in the casino
talking about this like you know you're
[__] hilarious and I was telling tone
and he goes but what if the white man's
all right to go nah guys like that and
there's some guy walking by yeah how
does she wiped you with a ponytail like
nah that guy gets to fight that dude is
going to be highly confident though and
only
strong men from the Congo they don't
know what race they think you're gonna
get a little a Juan from
yeah you're getting some 6'3 from the
Congo that will crush your skull
so basically what I'm saying this is a
game show to beautiful racist wife yeah
no this is like a Chicago you know take
it off not just white men oh racists any
racists I've seen racist Mexican I've
seen racist black people I've seen races
Asian people
just racists in general
old versus white man
yeah you can you can always when you put
a color or race you can always go now I
can see what you're saying that's why I
always describe him like I was fighting
this dude he's a little guy about like
well imagine little Mexican dude shaved
head because then you're like oh I'm
there I know exactly what you're I'll
fight him so anyway that'd be a good
game show yeah yeah
and or just you know like thing the
government does
okay like all right like a hunger game
style
[Laughter]
I love it
you never ordered a coffee uncomfortable
moment along the same lines you're
you're at a coffee shop and there's a
black Barista like you go to order a
coffee and they're like no cream no
sugar
no no just just black
yeah I guess
whatever you say sir no cream no sugar
so so you wanted black just dark make
color just I don't see colors man that's
a good one I I don't see in colors all
right all right I don't see colors I
only see in spirits and attitudes and
yours is bright
I'll just take the cook I'll take the
cream of sugar just give me some cream
of sugar yeah
there's a lot of
there's a lot of times where I'm like I
wish I could record this and just spit
it out onto a stage because sometimes
shit's just too funny but it's so either
damn that was [__] insane to say or
like damn those kind of racist but funny
as hell that's the borderline that I
were trying to tiptoe I'm trying to
tiptoe almost dark humor
but sometimes it's just real life
yeah that's all
um
oh oh yeah
the other one oh
all right here we go
I had a racist realization
with Marty as I was talking about it and
I was like yo I'ma write that down
just talked about the show
I love doing this show I had a racist
realization that I am racist in
occasions there's situations and for
people that clip that and go damn this
Fool's an idiot why are you saying
racist situations
hear me out
every time I walk into a plane
that I'm getting on and I see at least
a majority of white flight attendants or
or co-pilots or probably go
thank God
because my thing is like the government
would never let a plan go down full of
happy smiling white white women from
Denver Colorado or Omaha or whatever and
I think that I think that but I walk in
I see a bunch of fools that look like me
like yo this plane could go down and no
one's going to report it on the news bro
I I feel like I'm not important enough
like
I just gotta walk around like this and
be like yo
covers my new store I get deleted a lot
I get deleted so much and I look at my
face though damn it they don't care but
every time I walk Rosie knows it's like
oh
a lot of our cousins on this plane
a lot of brown people working government
doesn't care about us
I'm nervous that's what I'm like now I'm
nervous every every piece of turbulence
I'm like oh this is it oh god I've never
once racially profiled my attendance or
felt safer because of their whiteness I
do
would you call them white attendants
instead of flight attendants I need some
white attendants because if it's gonna
go down the government's gonna be like
no you look at the log you see who's on
there it's women will produce the golden
children like they are blonde essence or
whatever you want to say or call it
that's how I feel remember these are all
things that I can say on stage and not
get in trouble for and I don't care if
you get in trouble we're gonna get in
trouble
the [__] out of here this is crazy it
sure doesn't [__] it's not monetized
in the first [__] yeah we're not even
monetized suck a dick
wow
that one I like
I am gonna do my first
I can't [__] wait and I'm gonna have
a sound bit every time I say something
go laugh
black
I like that
but it's just
we do it I'd be sick
wear a shirt that has a cricket on it
it's funny that our our mascot's a
cricket
yeah it's never quiet
did you oh you don't want to give me my
other joint oh no what's that out later
we got this guy
there was point one left I'm like I'm
gonna see if I can roll it and then it
rips I'm like damn it now I gotta put
the tip in the other end so that's why
it's all shaped dumb
just save that for gas when they're too
intimidated like yo you smoke yeah I
smoke a little got you bro
[__] chilly
welcome to the dope as usual podcast get
ready to go to the Moon that's what my
little Lackawanna Johnson look back that
sucks the first one I ever will look at
identical to this
just garbage garbage joint
terrible anyway
um
I can say whatever I don't care
I always like oh here's here's something
else I came to the realization I was in
Las Vegas why do I think I'm I was at
Champs just bored
I was at the event I was at the booth
just bored thinking of horrible [__]
I thought you know what sick
Rosie's half Filipino
I
D her family someone family members look
Asian
I've been asked by hey man you parties
or something like no I'm just high as
[__] I guess why do I people ask me
actually if I'm Islander a lot
right but a lot of people like oh
Rosie's mixed with some like yeah she's
Filipino
my child is gonna look
Asian
I never thought about like my future
kids are gonna be look just like me
Rosie and I mixed together
and I'm gonna have like an Asian little
daughter or son I never thought about
that
the way Rosie's family looks and I get
it but like little me and little her
oh bro
that's what I would imagine because
the little the little baby versions of
roses of pictures of Rosie
that's why I think this I've seen all
her pictures on her mom's wall and I go
that's what our child's gonna look like
just a little
a tiny girl with chopped bowl cut long
hair so I always think like wow I never
thought about it I'm on a little
Filipino babies this is going to be
tight I never thought about it and then
I go now I can make Asian jokes because
like my kids are Asian boy calm down but
I can make Jewish jokes my whole
family's Jewish I can make Mexican jokes
look at my skin I can make white jokes
my aunt's name is Marcia like I'm like
and then I thought I'm gonna be like the
Power Ranger thing that locks up
but of the Power Ranger guy of making
racist jokes and I have all the ammo and
you can't say anything to me ever
for all the people that want to cancel
go you're going to try to cancel a
Jewish man
you're gonna try to cancel a man that
has Asian children
You're Gonna Cancel
with his Grandpa's from Mexico
how are you black yeah how yeah how am I
black we got to figure out like there's
gotta be
yeah you're just a grandpa like bro my
great great great great grandpa was
homies with Mr Edwards great grandpa
don't ever say some [__] to me yo I am
the full Megatron
Lock and Load Asian jokes Jewish jokes
Mexican joke that's how I feel right now
like I can say anything I want it's
gonna have some kids
I can't say [__]
must be nice
[Laughter]
[Music]
you sat down and immediately said it
though that was like it was scripted I
loved that that was I hope yeah you got
a camera on these things [__]
tripping burning burn that's a linen
Papa's yo
that was incredible timing Marty
that was
insane I can't say [__] Mario's gonna be
in the back going
technically I can't even laugh at this
[__] oh no I don't know do whatever
comedy knows no color or bounds
sometimes Kramer Michael riches you
[__] today
you [__] it up prove that wrong
how can you [__] comedy up don't worry
after about six years eight years after
Seinfeld Kramer's gonna [__] it up
isn't that crazy Kramer the coolest guy
in Seinfeld is the one that's a monster
in first then again I get what he was
doing
because he's racist like I get it you're
racist no but you see that and he
explained itself I'm like you just let
it fly that's all he did was just let it
fly I love Michael Richards but you let
it fly that little bit of whatever
happened to bring it all out like that
into a psychotic [__] ramp
that still lingers to this day
in like 15 years all he'll ever be is he
the luckiest person alive
to not have gotten stomped to a [__]
pulp that night Andrew since then he's
huge dude he's a big guy
I think a lot of people just
screamer I guess I think that might
intimidate a lot of people like oh damn
it was big like yeah he's a big guy he
even seem to slide into Jerry's
apartment [__] that that those
racial words though that'll [__]
discount your height real quick
discounts yeah no just a lot of people
were just all talk on the internet if I
ever see you in person like bro you saw
him today how many times I had people
talk [__]
he's not still a comedian right no no no
no no no no no no no no no no I think he
just got I think he's just Michael
Richards now
that guy that was in Angels in the
Outfield
or was it Angels in the Outfield yeah
remember he's the wait
no might be a different movie he's one
of the like the team managers in the old
movie I can't remember
anyway
racialization
I love to racism
that's from Eastbound and Down that's a
good one I say I love to racism a lot
hey man it's funny if it's funny it's
funny damn we won we're on a rant right
there but
but
I'm having block him loaded one day I'm
gonna be bulletproof you're a creative
player for [__] this [__] there was a
kid he'll get like make him slightly
brown but he could look white in some
outfits I guess he'll look kind of way
Rosie's Grandma thought I was white
until the day she died
I remember saying that crazy
bro I mean I looked at like this my
whole life until like high school and
then I got darker so I I get it I get it
I like the average Jewish kid
dark hair light skin like because my
grandma looks like just straight Jewish
woman looking black hair white the
whitest skin like um
when I
learned in the books that's what they
would they would search for but go look
at that guy and uh I gotta camp for you
look at that hair that's how they would
pick people out I'm like damn dude my
grandma would never made it she looks
just like a Jewish lady that's so sad
it's insane it's insane I've considered
that I think about it when we studied in
school like
bro what just walking down the street
you just don't go home nah
get me on a boat I'll take I'll fight
Poseidon before I fight these crazy
Germans what happened how did we get on
this topic I have no clue I have no clue
but while we're doing this Jesus Christ
oh my God can you uh go to the fan
questions real quick
Jesus I just looked at this racial
realization racist fight illegals
not our usual topics
all right all right you ready for this
guys
fan questions what time are we at I'm
gonna say hour five
hour ten okay this [__] weed is
delicious look at this
it's burning good yes
God damn
all right
oh I finally bought a pound I bought a
pound of this
fire happy with it
I spent a long [__] time
oh my God before we get into this real
quick have you been seeing all these
videos about people testifying to seeing
aliens and [__]
no the second I see alien stuff anywhere
on the news I scroll right past it
because I've been knowing about this
[__] and I said one day they're gonna
like open it all up and they're gonna
show it all over the news and they're
gonna and No One's Gonna care
a board I mean that kind of feels like
what's happening I mean today I think
was a little different because you had
former military people you know under
oath eight years ago they would have got
shot for talk about that now it's cool
why because the government's talking
about something bigger and they're doing
something bigger than like throwing the
aliens yeah throw them the [__] that we
found out in the 60s you know what I'm
saying because but also I don't care I
don't give a [__] I'm just smoking weed
I'm gonna go home I don't care
government I have to say that but uh the
one dude uh this dude here Stephen Greer
he looks familiar he actually looks like
an alien yeah he watches his interview
here the way he moves around is very
it's just kind of Men In Black heated me
last night during the push trees meeting
Jay brought it up he's like yo you're
about the aliens nah bro that's big [__]
and I'm like you know what's crazy
we've been in this meeting for two hours
you're just bringing it up if this was
10 years ago
you had been outside when you came to
the meeting you had been freaking out
everybody sees it it would have been the
biggest thing ever now we're smoking
joints oh yeah by the way did you see
that alien uh
I didn't see him anymore Y2K type of
show it's not the same no more that's
true nobody gives a [__] that's
interesting I didn't realize we were at
that point I think so I don't care
anymore I know
until Independence Day kicks off people
have just been too Bamboozled about it I
feel like well I I don't wanna
I'm not gonna get into that
I think I've talked to you about it
we'll just leave I'm that's all and
that's all I got to say bro
let's leave it be
I've seen too many things and know too
many things in my life and seen too much
[__] in my life to go
so now you want to talk about it
shut the [__] up
I'll let it be
but yeah we're talking about last night
I'm crazy
it is wild
um sorry
fan questions you guys ready for this
first up Instagram if we we asked this
to this morning boom a flyer on our
Instagram to open usual podcast drop a
fan question to be featured on the show
that's how you see all these people
that's why we pop up their names because
they're participating we appreciate you
we could just take the question and
never say the name we got this question
from a fan no we want to show Bradley
8802 or 8801 we want to show that like
thank you bro because I hope that was at
home of course oh you should make my
[__] when I messaged the giveaway
winners that feels so great and guess
what we got the future fans thing going
on the Highlight now we got the [__]
winners going up on the store you live
on the page you get tagged we do ever we
collab posts with you I like everything
we possibly can we try to do for sure
all right thank you little [__] just
just stuff I mean thank you
but this one this is a good question and
I this is very relevant
so from Bradley 8801 what's a good way
to manage your time when you're not when
you're always so busy I just have so
much to do and I'm not sure if I have
enough time for the things that would
help me in the future
mm-hmm you're you are a master at this
so go yeah the only way to do it is with
a routine
and the routine has to be the same every
day basically and consistent you gotta
look at how many hours are in the day
and then map out what you're gonna do
and then really do it
generally speaking like we saw with
Jeezy this [__] kicks off at about 5 A.M
that's just a brutal fact of [__]
life that you got to accept if you
really want to get your time under
control for me and a lot of success like
people I feel like most people who get
in the routine of like going to sleep
around nine waking up at like five doing
the same [__] every day your body gets
in that momentum by the time nine ten
rolls around it feels like the [__]
day is almost over but you get so much
done
work personal life [__] kid [__] running
around Fitness [__] for the house chores
like all this needs to really be thought
out and planned otherwise you're gonna
start having big time stressors in your
life if you're not [__] checking all
these boxes
you can't if you're really trying to be
on point what's your schedule in the
morning morning
I try to explain it to Jay last night my
schedule is pretty [__] simple no I'm
yeah I mean your schedule's packed yeah
when it's Sports time work time and all
this [__] oh yeah that that that should
go it gets insane what's your schedule
right now yeah so right now it's like
because I haven't been going to the gym
since the marathon I've been my workout
time has been social media time for the
podcast that's what I'm trying to manage
so it's like getting up between five
five thirty and then right away it's
like
checking emails checking the messages
what are we posting so then I start
making Clips so I make the clips make
thumbnail get all that going I'm
responding to [__] and then it's like
take the kids to school come back now I
got the dope is Yola [__] going and then
you know we got full day worth of
editing we're posting I'm constantly
dming and doing [__] on Instagram I got
the iPad going on the side of the
computer now I got multiple things going
we're going crazy right now with the
podcast so all kinds of [__] is going on
at the [__] drastic Graphics
headquarters and then it turns 11 at in
the afternoon yeah then what do you do
here's motherfucker's doing all this
[__] well it's still dark yeah we
the mornings are sacred that [__] is
time to just go quiet time you're up
before the competition but it's the
routine it's the sameness is what really
breeds the results because if you just
wake up and the day is just happening to
you and you're like I used to wake up
like the latest that I could before I'd
have to leave out to go to work it's the
worst thing that you can do you want to
have the day on your time and to be
ahead of it so you're not rushing
number one thing I hate doing is rushing
or being late hustling to get somewhere
because I'm [__] late let alone do it
every single day that's not life like
I've seen in cam cam gets up like me
early without even an alarm when he has
to go to school he's just chilling and
[__] doing having his little routine
before he has to go and do his [__] I
don't know but I'm just trying to manage
if because I got to get back in the gym
I gotta and I want to make my course
this is something that we're trying to
manage and figure out right now for the
rest of the year is how I'm gonna design
my day to make all that happen and keep
keep everything pushing forward so we
got a good plan
we got a good plan right now like we
were talking about yesterday we're in uh
we're in like
uh sales mode right now so we're
building everything back up
with our ad partners and then we're
gonna build up our team a little bit and
then we're gonna shift some things
around so that I can do all the [__] we
can keep pushing forward but it's just
part of the process
that morning routine though that daily
routine that consistency Bradley she
just made me tired yeah thinking about
it I mean it sounds daunting but once
you get into the routine of it you
realize it's the only way you got to
design your day Rob Dyrdek
so Bradley
still figuring that out
I talked about on live yesterday
I talk I mean we talk all the time but
since first grade my report card say
does not manage time wisely
it's just the truth I am the biggest
procrastinator ever
this is this is how I think my my brain
goes
hey
do something we have to do this thing
for the for the rehab shop okay cool
well I'll send that off oh by the way we
have to send something to an ad person
cool Google the push tree designs came
in okay check them out do you like them
all right yeah for sure check out the
emails because I had a bunch of AD
people coming in for dope okay got it
all right check us out the dopest we got
these flyers this and we gotta get this
video off by this day okay cool
um let's uh do this oh by the way now
it's
but I went to bed at three in the
morning and I woke up at 9 30 or 10 late
as hell
for doing business [__]
and then what happened I woke up my oh
my God my back's so stiff oh my God my
foot's gone you know that that damn
planets beside his [__] right and then
my stomach before I stopped eating this
stuff right and then my stomach's
constantly hurting and I had that
deviated septum I feel sick and hurt and
I go who cares about how I feel I got to
get all the things I just named off
right so I'm doing all these things
doing all this stuff I'm on the computer
I'm doing comments I'm doing all this
stuff and by the time I know it's like
three hours I'm like damn three hours
gone by I haven't drank water I haven't
ate anything I haven't looked up I have
a headache from strolling and doing
things and going off to 10 different
apps
doing all the same posts and going wait
did I post that on that app yet oh [__]
that's Instagram I can't post wheat on
there oh bam I'm gonna go over here and
they're like all right cool for the
dopest let's do this and I'm doing stuff
for push trees and then also I'm like
hey Rosie what are you doing okay we'll
do this we'll do that oh wait what the
hell I got the car wash guy coming let
me we'll go do all this stuff real quick
boom here take that then I come back in
and then all the whole time I have a
scene from a movie playing constantly in
my head and then a song over here I have
80d
like I have a songs playing in my head
constantly and then scenes for movies or
shows or stuff that I've done playing
over here and then this part gets used
for like the business [__] and then
sometimes I go I got a lot to do
I should probably call it [__] doctor
for my back I need to get a chiropractor
they start stretching you know I need to
start stretching all right let me look
for a chiropractor
boom Oh I got 12 text messages about
dopest
oh [__] yeah I'll find a chiropractic
right now six weeks goes by before I
think about my back again and I'm doing
the same routine and then what happens
it's 5 40 at night in the afternoon like
I haven't eaten
all right I should probably order food
or make food you know I can't make food
I can just order food right now while
I'm doing these new emails oh [__] I
forgot I have a video dropping today
boom in the live chat doing the live
chat reading comments but now my head
hurts still haven't drink water today
not anyone's fault but mine but I never
think about those things I'm like oh I
feel sick there's a lot of times I'm
working to go
oh
okay I went by I got like a heat of like
Provo eat I get like you know when you
get sick from not eating like I get like
doubles to gargle
and I go all right and Rosie's
everything Thomas please need something
I go Rosie if you want to order some
wood you want I go I don't want anything
I feel sick why do you have to drink
water nothing sounds bomb when you're
just
the whole time I'm dabbing my ass off
while I'm taking all these videos and
I'm smoking because I'm like oh John
came by let's take a bunch of dabs yeah
I'm doing these emails bro uh let's go
live while you're here bam then what now
it's eight o'clock and what have I done
nothing and I go damn dude how am I
gonna get better if I don't stretch if I
don't work out I should have made time
for that maybe I should not go to bed at
three in the morning and then what
happens I have insomnia until
I started just going to bed laying there
not touch not looking at my phone
whatsoever and the TV can be on but my
back hurts so bad I can't sit up in bed
like that so I have to stare at the
ceiling like a kid again
I'd have fallen asleep though so that's
been helping but I'll fall asleep but
like I still haven't eaten yet and I
ordered food now it's what 9 30 or 10. I
can't go to sleep like three hours after
I eat now it's one and now it's one in
the morning Rosie's been asleep for an
hour I'm just by myself like now I'm
just scrolling I'm like I can't do
nothing it's night time I'm not gonna go
run on the treadmill it's 1 30 in the
morning
I'm not gonna go in the sauna and
stretch it's 1 30 in the morning I'll
wait to the morning I'll get up early in
the morning I'm gonna start tomorrow
six years later
now it's seven years later eight years
nine years later the same thing I feel
like that's like 99 of people that is my
brain though and I just don't feel good
because everything hurts all the time
because I'm not taking care of it over
and over because I don't think I bro I
gotta be I gotta pay for all this [__] I
know you got like how many people go I
gotta make Ripple I don't care if I feel
sick
I'm not trying to make rent anymore but
I'm like bro I got things to do I I I'll
worry about this later
and I always think I'll do it's all I'm
gonna figure it out I'm not gonna just
like be sick all the time I'm not gonna
let my back hurt forever but I wake up
and if my back doesn't hurt it's a
[__] miracle it's happened three
times in like seven years
I wake up I'm like oh [__]
happened last week which was insane I
woke up my mag didn't hurt at all
it was wild anyway we had the trainer
though so the trainer comes by I'm like
oh yeah the trainer okay a trainer and
then okay wait I got a film today ah
[__] and to say the dopest we don't get
the stuff in time and I had to change my
film day
now that [__] all my whole scheduling
up and you know what I mean it's just
and it's just it's in a constant
rotation of that
and then I'm not stretching because I'm
like bro
my back hurts I don't want to try to
stretch it it hurts like bro you have to
stretch through that that's how it gets
better and then you got I know a lot of
you fools out there like bro that [__]
hurts I don't want to be doing that
but it's never any better if you don't
do it and then what happened I started
getting the routine stretching before I
go to sleep and right when I wake up for
like 10 minutes
and I was chugging nothing but water the
second I wake up chugging water
and I started feeling better and what
happened which New York my mom my two
months ago I didn't do it for like a
week fell off of it
and what happened I told Rosie I haven't
been stretching for like two three weeks
and Rosie goes
we went to New York in May
I thought it was like in early July or
June
it's been two months plus I haven't been
stretching or doing my routines in the
morning
what and then what happens when I wake
up I wake up at 10 I got 47 text
messages from people
and I would I do the second wake up am I
deleted anywhere
I wake up and immediately do this turn
my alarm off and do this I can't even
open my eyes yet I'm checking all my
accounts to make sure they're there like
oh yeah we're good damn I've already
posted some wild [__] on the page every
morning that's how I wake up damn
already posted some [__] that's like one
of the first things I posted my job post
was hilarious because one of the first
things I see
that's awesome I am running my body into
the ground and my brain and my stamina
and my youth because I'm stressing
myself out
so I started trying again and then what
happened that [__] how old is Jeezy
can we look up how old he is
and it's so weird like sometimes you
just gotta see it and hear it I've heard
people have schedules before 45. the
man's 45 years old and he heard his
schedule yeah I wake up and I'm gonna
say I eat fruit I drink water or tea
with honey and lemon in it or hot water
with tea and lemon
meditate for 30 minutes
stretch for 45.
then go to the gym because it's barely
six in the morning now
come on man he's getting up at five so
the past three nights
we haven't been able we had a meeting
until 1 30 in the morning last night I
didn't get to eat until one in the
morning last night
I could order food while we're doing the
meeting I just it was in my head it
wasn't in my head I'm not doing other
[__] I'm doing so much stuff we're
talking about something and Rosie's like
you should order and they ordered food
I'll look right now I'll look right now
my brain is
does this constantly and then I'm like
and I've had the damn uh put on song by
Jesus seven minutes no why we've been
talking about this the song Just I had
it in a mad for weeks oh it's just
playing in my head right now so it's
like while we're talking about this
conversation I've let this joint burn
that song's still playing in my head or
like right here
it's like it's like a basket I can put
things in my and they all play at the
same time I always describe it to Rosie
as The Truman Show when he can hear
everybody's prayers at once that's how
my brain works and I [__] hate it
dude I'll have multiple songs playing at
once it's like it's like playing two
radios at once but I go shut one off
please I think we've talked about the
show before
I think I'm starting to get better
though
like when I watch something I'm gonna
start just watching something when I go
to the theater I don't think like that
because there's nothing else in the
world it's rude to be on your phone it's
rude to answer emails you can't talk to
the next person because that's rude at
home do whatever the [__] I want
so I'm trying to treat it like yo just
watch it don't watch it while answering
emails and then have to rewind because I
didn't watch it while Rosie's sitting
there watching the same scene three
times because I was answering
comments I don't fully do anything
that's for my own health or brain except
the trainer
but even with a trainer every time she's
like all right 30 second break I'm
looking at my phone to make sure I don't
got any text or calls I'm like all right
cool
so I don't ever do something without
like being attached to like do I got to
get something done that's not good yeah
I gotta start separating that a little
more that's all
that's it and
that's what I tried to do last night
when you get to bed too late but I still
woke up earlier it's like you know what
I'm gonna be exhausted but it's cool
because I think everybody sleep I was
gone all last week and we're up gambling
and doing Casino [__] and then waking up
going to the event and then driving
straight to Merced and then getting hell
up hella early to do the gender reveal
and then Rosie
went to bed at 10 had to get up at 1 40
or 2 No 2 30 for the raise and eat
before
so I was up until 2 30 damn near what if
I couldn't really put two episodes in
there
of what to film two episodes in the mix
in the mix of that I would have done it
though yeah for sure oh it done and
drove in the morning all the way through
to four in the morning I don't give a
[__]
I broke my candy streak I had to use
some candy on the dry bag from Merced
because lollipops keep me awake because
I'm crunching I'm trying to stay awake
that's what helps me in smoking no never
mind
I don't smoke joints in jail it's the
only thing keeps me awake and I was just
watching Jersey Shore or listening to it
like damn these [__] are crazy
as I'm drowning on the Grapevine just
trying to stay awake because I left I
left uh San Francisco two in the
afternoon my my cousin she's in the
hospital up there
and I went and visited her I was gonna
be there for an hour stay for like three
and a half hours that's awesome right it
just turned into that but I left San
Francisco at 450 the worst time on life
to leave then I stopped to my cousins in
Ripon for two hours now it's seven or
eight o'clock and I didn't tell you what
happened I'll tell you guys what
happened
you get into Merced and I'm like I guess
I'll eat Habit Burger since I'm it's got
gluten though and you know what I mean
like I'm eating bread I'm [__] up I
don't there's nothing I haven't eaten
and what am I doing guys
I get food
me and Rosie get on the road right it's
middle like it's like eight o'clock at
night I've been driving for like six
hours total I'm just I'm just exhausted
from the whole week here's a little
story
the dumbest [__] I ever did it's the
first time it's ever happened to me I've
been driving for a while
me and Rosie
Rosie and I get on uh
freeway you know back from getting food
and then we leave Merced
driving from Merced I passed Madera
about 30 minutes
pass Madera go to this gas station I've
never been to
go to the gas station
Marty haven't told you
you know pump my gas like a regular
human being grab some more lollipops
and then I get on the road I look it
says 99 South right there on the left 99
North right there on the right I go
south because that's where I'm going I'm
on the freeway I'm watching
Jersey Shore family reunion or family
vacation I got stuck on your short damn
it I never watched before in my life
Rose used to watch me first started
dating I thought it was the dumbest [__]
ever never watched it started watching
it now I'm just like
all right what is Ronnie doing I gotta
watch Jersey Shore where's Pauly D so
I've been I've been watching your store
when I go on long trips I put the
whatever movie or show we're watching
and I just drive and listen and if
there's nobody in front of me I'll take
a couple peeks you guys know what I'm
talking about I'll just look every
couple seconds or every like 10 seconds
like oh they're fighting oh they're
fighting oh [__] tell me what happens oh
[__] it just passes the time right
so I'm driving crunching lollipops not
smoking fat joints of this delicious
weed is what I'm not doing
and I'm doing this and as I crunch my
delicious lollipop in half
I look up and I go why does it say
Merced on this sign
I got on the wrong [__] ex ramp and
drove back to Merced
and I looked at Rosie and we looked and
I'm like we caught on a 99 North I'm
exhausted I just drove 20 [__]
minutes the wrong way
and I got off and then me and Rosie
could not for the life of us remember
how it happened because I was so stuck
on watching Ronnie fight
on Jersey Shore
but I went back and me and Rosie both
specifically remember looking and
getting on the left side and it said 99
south on the left
anyway guys for the first time in my
life I got on the wrong
freeway or the wrong ramp and I drove
back the opposite way as I was already
falling asleep tired as hell and I was
so mad at myself couldn't believe it
a John Denver's full of [__] man get out
of here
get the [__] out of here we bring up so
many Jim Carrey movies it's kind of
insane so I can see why you were saying
that I thought the Rocky Mountains well
Rock you're in this you you driving the
wrong way I felt so stupid Marnie
I've been there I oh I've been there
I fakely smoked a badass joint and I ate
a whole lollipop
that's how long it took me to realize I
was going the wrong way
I've never done that all the trips of
ever in my life I've drove million miles
I've drove so much delivering packs and
doing stupid [__] and pizza never have I
drove the wrong way anywhere
come on bro I know where I'm going it's
Le it's up or down it's one street that
goes way worse at the end of like uh a
long trip a long ass week and I couldn't
wait to get home I was so tired
so that happened oh management time why
did this happen why I didn't even say my
oh I went in my long rant that's how my
brain works so the reason I bring it all
up is
what if I fixed my back and you know my
stomach got better and I kept up with
this trainer which I'm doing
but I just got up earlier and just you
know maybe I'll run three miles before
the Sun's Up not try to squeeze it in
before it [__] dropped going all
right I got 45 minutes my schedule like
this in the day my schedule does nothing
in the morning because nobody nobody's
doing [__] for seven
you know I mean no one's coming over to
do stuff at seven
we're not we're not posting videos on
YouTube at seven in the morning doing
chats I need those hours where no one
will bug me I need that 5 30 to nine
so ever since Jeezy was like no I get up
in the morning where I'm like trapping
not real estate like
the way you think it made me think a
little differently I like that that's
cool and coming from somebody that's so
established like bro that you get up at
[__] you have so much discipline in your
Subway well I need I need it like bro I
need it like I do need what's the
difference between being an entrepreneur
and Mr rich guy
he's like I'm [__] pushing I like
that you're just a rich organization to
keep pushing forward dude I just need to
get better in my life I need my [__] to
progress I need to progress because
I'm stagnantly staying in the same spot
and just leveling up like this
but I could just be going straight up
bro I'm trying to get on Men's Health
Magazine like yo this pothead little kid
just got rocked like yeah Men's Health
give me a check mark
something I guess Forbes don't matter
dude Men's Health
Good Housekeeping exactly dude I just
need to do something with myself so
right now I'm still trying to manage my
time could you imagine if I was in my
time and schedules but could you imagine
make it just do it tomorrow exactly it's
not that easy the thing is for me is
that I don't I used to get up real early
my whole life and worked Ella early in
Portland and get up for the bus at five
and do all that [__] it was I'm I'm
tired but I still had to do it I'd be
like I'll sleep tomorrow I'll sleep
tonight how many times you get up and go
oh I can't wait to come home tonight
just go to sleep
early I used to do that because I'm
insomnia I'd go to sleep at four in the
morning wake up at seven to school and
like I'm gonna go to sleep early tonight
tonight's the night I've been saying
this since fourth grade
that's not good fourth grade I've been
inspired that's not good I don't have a
good sleep schedule because I used to
not be able to sleep now I can sleep I
just push it cause I'm doing so much
[__] I need to stop doing that that's
all I always think if I started I get
done today what the [__] it's got to be
finished today all of it has to be done
what so when you guys have a kid
eventually that's gonna force you into
that shot yeah but I'm trying to do it
now dude I might try to like
because you're here now I have to get
better like I want to do it for myself
you know I just want to lead into that
[__]
on my own it's not easy it takes a lot
of effort because it doesn't and I don't
have a child or responsibility to get up
at six so I don't do it yeah
but that's dumb
imagine what I could do if I felt better
you know I can get on a lie for 25
minutes at 8 30 in the morning like yo
I'm on live what's up guys I'm not about
to head out the gym I always think
everything is like whoa I really did
that I'm not gonna go to the gym I
already did my work I'm tired I realizes
I'll do that tomorrow that's how I
always feel that's why it has to be done
early like uh it's Rosa she gets up and
works out she say I won't do it later
like [__] I would like to do it at night
do you would you
you don't do it at night [__] working
out at night never happens [__] like no
no it doesn't
I have a gym in miles I still want this
[__] at night
I just got to start doing I just got to
start utilizing the day I don't I
haven't seen the morning sun and [__]
years
like the five o'clock Sun
that [__] just reminds me of headaches
to Hangovers I get bummed out if I wake
up and the sun's out
I really need to get there I can't wait
till I'm there uh so guys
there's there's thing like look I gotta
work on that everything is always a work
in progress got it what I have the other
thing to keep in mind because
oh something's always something's always
that's just the reality of it
something's always going to be needing
extra work and not gonna be [__]
perfect and everything look at that
[__] Cannon the cannon
smoke this Chopper
this is a joke joint I'm just kidding
it's like a wick it's
fake
it's what I like my bowls with
my joint's been [__] burning
perfectly ever since I learned how to
light them correctly too by the way I
don't know if you've noticed yeah they
burn so much better yeah oh sorry I just
got this sorry sorry sorry sorry
we'll show it over the screen skateboard
coming soon
that's amazing dang
and with the cross joint
as I imagine my childhood look like
because he's gonna be [__] Filipino
for real though it looks like me but
slightly not me yeah like younger a
teenager yeah a little teenage version
to me
that's sick ass artwork isn't it big
that's where the trucks will go
wow don't throw it up over the screen or
maybe I'll I'll ask our guy maybe we
should I don't know
isn't it hard in fact they put the
crossturn on there it's crazy I asked
them well I was like oh let's go
Blasphemous let's put the cross joint
burn it on there
first one ever for a skateboard
[__] I'd love to see the uh different
products coming about yeah I'm excited
um so yeah work in progress guys
managing time oh God that was the first
one all right let's go to the next oh
oh we could have we could have a show
just us and we never had to bring
another human being in this place and
just talk forever especially with
questions yeah oh with stuff that we
don't have to go all right let's talk
about this like oh you asked me uh let
me elaborate [__]
up next Kane Birch what should be the
first step
or one of the top questions what should
the first step be for someone wanting to
start recording videos make sure it's
the rec is on click
been there I was kidding but I have been
there too for sure the first thing you
do make sure that shit's recording and
all how many times ago is it Rec though
and it's blinking I asked bulls that all
the time the numbers are going on my
phone
all right 10 minutes to do a video go
you didn't press start
[__] I can't fake this emotion oh that
is a good part I was gonna say I'll be
in stories like I can't just
uh it's acting I'm not an actor
I'm just talking I can't then it has to
be a different part
every time I say something like that's
probably gonna be really good on camera
it's probably gonna be funny
sometimes I make myself laugh like
hold on I'll just cut that I mean you
edit the shade so you know what the [__]
I'm talking about
I'm telling you you know the [__] we cut
out the [__] you cut out
um the first step in recording videos
make sure it's something that you think
is fun
I didn't make videos because I was like
I want to be a film guy I was like yo
weed [__] I [__] with you can record
that you can put on the internet make
sure it's something you like that's it
that's the first thing make sure you're
doing something that you think is cool
for first I've met some people are like
well you know I made videos and I was
like well I could make weed videos you
know like wait you didn't smoke weed
before like well I mean I I did I smoked
mine like smoke all I don't have a pipe
or anything my
weed content he just started smoking
yesterday basically I'm like hey
[Music]
good for you but also
um
not in a bad way but it's more like
hey hit this so I don't know I know
you're not a cop that's like that's that
drug dealer [__] like you better snort
that too so I know you're down hey man
you started smoking yesterday
no I don't wanna do a video right now
yeah
I don't know dude because I I'm not a
content creator I'm a guy that used to
sell drugs that turned into guy that
made videos and now they call that a
content creator
it's a fair [__] point it's a true
story it's a true statement never
thought we'd be doing this [__]
so it's it's crazy so make sure you do
something you like
because if it's explicit you know how
many people want to start it you're
going to regret this when you're 40.
wait till you have kids you're going to
regret making these videos
no
shit's tight
not at all but if I had that in the back
of my head
who was it
um there's a there's a a page on YouTube
ligor there's a page on YouTube he does
like cannabis content he did a video
there's this guy named Indy he was an
old YouTube weed guy I never made videos
with him but I saw a lot of people I
just don't like making videos of that
many people
until I know them or till I can go hey
they're not just somebody that's coming
into space trying to get paid and turns
out they were [__] weird as hell
doing weird [__] they got a record on
some their Creeks or that's full
snitches or this fool you just do this
or he solves fentanyl I don't know what
it is I don't know you so I'm not gonna
put you right on my platform like that
we we researched the guests
we researched the guests we bring on
here
how many times like it took like three
months of us checking out Goblin's
content they were like we should we
should add some of the show yeah because
you brought them up I'm like I mean I
don't know him say my fulcrum same with
Focus I don't know them so let me watch
her [__] for a little bit make sure they
don't like they're chill that's what
happened aircon I knew him before I
started a podcast that's like why it was
fine
but you know what I'm saying like we got
to make sure dude like we content
creators don't have imbds
they don't have wikipedias we can't go
and they're cool right they didn't like
do some wild [__] in high school like
they're like racist you remember
something crazy anyway there's this guy
they've ever you should make a video
with that guy and the reason I don't I
didn't because I don't know that person
and I wanted to watch their content for
a couple weeks or months to make sure
I'm like oh I [__] with this person this
is sick [__] that's what we did to
Goblin I watched one video he made me
crack the [__] up and that's right yo
this guy is hilarious we gotta get him
on
so
there's this guy Indy or whatever and
then I saw this this other YouTube page
do it he made weed content right
and they became cop stop making Wii
content became a cop
and then asked a YouTuber to take down
the videos that they did together
because it looks bad on him
yeah it looks bad on you you're a cop
you're the opposite of what you used to
be cop where
I don't know but
which is cool and that's your career be
a cop bro I'm not down you caught we
Nika I'm gonna call the cops if I need
you there's some places now that the
cops are all pro weed and [__] I get
that but it's like
you're asking to take down the videos
that you used to make sure to hide it
you're trying to hide who you used to be
you probably shouldn't have been what
you were his wife probably made him go
get a job type of [__] you know so so
the reason I'm saying that what do you
do for the first step for recording
videos make sure you're not ashamed of
that [__] because it never stops like
it's forever it's not just like writing
your name on a wall it gets painted over
yeah
they don't teach you at film scores the
endurance it's going to take to
consistently put out videos for [__]
ever I always put that little baby doing
I'll just
pulling them things out there yeah
that's just a little joke yeah the
endurance aspect and being able to like
keep making stuff that people want to
watch I think is the real test to
somebody that's really good at doing
this [__] yeah
make it fun somebody should be able to
look at your page and know what it's
about right away there's another big
thing like that's how important the
direction is
yeah for me the other thing is like
you're gonna have to educate and
research that's a big [__] part of it
and you're doing yourself a huge
disservice if you don't
in terms of how to use the camera and
what the lens what the lenses do what
the different price ranges do
you're going to commit to learning that
[__] otherwise you're not really really
about it and you're gonna just lose a
lot of money and time and your [__]
could have been way better than it was
because you half-assed
this [__] going into it
so Kane Birch
that's what you should do
your research and know what you're doing
also make sure you love what you film
and I mean I'm a loving be a hobby but
make sure you like it what are you
offering people to what value like was
it how do you add value is it comedy is
it information is it entertaining
stories is it just relatability you're
like friendship type of thing like yeah
what are you giving people also one
thing I'll I'll suggest because I see a
lot of people do it
uh make content that like it's yours and
if it's a parody
you shouldn't let it be known that
that's why you're doing it that's that's
the joke is you're making fun of
the viral moment because a lot of people
I see that's why Tick Tock bugs me is
I'll be on content like I'll watch
someone do something hilarious
then four hours later I see a different
creator with like a big following do the
same [__] that person just did no credit
no nothing just like
like it's a template default to use
that's like a comedian just hearing it
go I'm going to the next room I'm gonna
use that I'm gonna use that right now
fish sticks like [__] Kanye South
Park like it's bro
so I see that a lot
before it was first step for someone to
start making videos make videos that
come from your brain
all right make your content like from
your brain and if it's something you're
inspired by I mean let it be known all
right let it be no like uh the eighth
video how fast can I smoke an eighth I
even said like yo raji's the first one I
ever saw do a timer and try to smoke a
gram fast like that's the first time I
saw and when I thought of this video go
did that
shout out to Royal G for because I
remember watching that video first it's
just
a community is a community if you like
really want people to help it could or
you really want people to do good around
you you can't just I want to be the
number one car guy and nobody else
exists like then you're gonna be the
[__] you ever seen uh Grandma's Boy
you're gonna be JP you're gonna be the
robot guy that nobody likes that he's
the best
but also no one cares because why
because he's a dick
just like with videos and genres and
music how many people out there go [__]
that producer for bites my sound you
know that's real that happens yeah of
course that happens in weed content too
believe it or not I've had a lot of
people try to pass off some stuff that
was mine
um I've had people take my exact
thumbnails and captions other YouTubers
popular series with the color branding
and things
yep
yeah it's pretty crazy
I've had a weedtuber tell me what I do
is I uh I go online I look up the most
popular videos I type in weed and I'll
go there and I'll just try to mimic that
because it went viral and in my head I
went oh
like I was like gross bro it's like you
can't explain to somebody what authentic
means in that instance like you're not
gonna understand this is how I this is
my cheat map you check out my cheat map
like
yeah I guess you could I mean you're
gonna do good for a while yeah but what
happens if nobody else makes content
you're not gonna make content because
you're just waiting for them to make
content so you can go I I I can do a
version of that yeah what am I good at
what do I like what do I know about what
value am I adding the other value yep
because if you're just mimicking other
people you're not adding no value
because you're they're paying you with
their time that is valuable that's very
that's the most valuable thing in the
universe this time
yeah truly
if you can't buy it it's the first thing
it's the only thing on Earth you can't
buy
that's why those 69 million hours or
whatever in the side of the [__]
months insane doesn't need it's just
like
we meet those people we see those people
in the comments there's a majority of
people we haven't even touched we
haven't seen them but they're watching
they're out there they're just actively
just listening to us talk about [__] it
makes me just so hyped
that's so cool really is super special
so that's what that's what you get in
this [__] for like what we just
described is like the reason why you
would want to get into videos as for a
situation you like it
yeah all right we can go to the next one
what is this Shea Lynn W do you fear
that oh oh damn it's kind of almost the
same thing
go ahead no go ahead it's all good do
you fear that people have a negative
opinion of you and feel disappointed in
you because of you do we content so I
remember why I brought that up
this weekend I won't say where
I won't say which party at one of the
parties
someone introduce yourself to me older
guy
like oh how do you know so and so part
of the family I'm like oh
well I told him to go oh
you're the guy that does the marijuana
stuff
like and when the wings said marijuana I
was like
where's this conversation going I'm
staring looking at the lake
I look at him I'm like yeah that's me
because
oh
and I was like
are you
disappoint like are you do you not like
that I don't I couldn't read the man I'm
like wow it's really hard to read you
how old was he like 60 because at first
I'm like yeah that's me I was like what
are you gonna say next I really want to
hear what you got to say next because
usually I wouldn't say [__] I didn't
bring up marijuana stuff oh yeah that
does the marijuana stuff
yeah
if you only [__] knew like you said I
was just waiting for it like
no that's it that's what you're gonna
say that's all
nice to meet you man
don't give a [__] but I was just waiting
like like in a cruise no like almost
like oh
oh yeah you're that guy
kind of like that I was like yeah I'm
that guy
Jesus Christ
I couldn't read you so that's how I feel
when people say like oh you're the guy
that does the Wii stuff if you're Edward
stizzy hands yes I've had people go oh
you the guy that does all that weed
content
yeah the [__] do I get the get away from
me bro I say something positive or why
are you speaking to me don't leave a bad
comment in real life the [__] just came
on my my wall to leave a comment on my
channel you're that guy like yeah what
of it fire Emoji I don't know
[__] what do I do
what do you got to say to me I don't
know that's how I feel like hmm
yeah I am
kind of goes into our last solo episode
we were talking about like
talking about this exact topic actually
yeah and I'm talking about like I need
to say yeah that's why I did it like
yeah that's me
and you said like oh well yeah and I do
clothing and stuff we respired we make
videos I would have just like toned it
down but I was waiting for it like what
are you gonna say next
totally nice didn't mean see me but I
was like
conversation just stopped when that
happened like I was I honestly dude I
was making small talk I didn't want to
make
I was only watching this child to make
sure he didn't even Wall fall in the
water couldn't give a [__] about what
you had to say I've never met you before
but nice to meet you oh that's how you
feel
that's how I felt
all right
didn't make me feel bad wasn't rude
nothing I just went hmm
don't care I felt judged thank you I
felt like
his judges shared me but also don't just
couldn't give a [__] I helped set all
this [__] up where are you
foreign
set this party up where were you that's
how I feel like I drove from La last
night you show up about an hour late I'm
the guy that does marijuana stuff but
I'm the guy that shows up on [__]
time
that's how I've kind of felt like hmm
where were you
yeah I set all that stuff up you're
sitting on there gotcha hi [__]
chill out but I didn't say anything I
just let it go but also it could have
been like
old man just like oh you're that guy
yeah he just he just stared off into
space yeah
yeah it just got
it froze I you can never know but all I
know is I was just waiting for the next
sentence and the next sense never again
nuggers and [__]
maybe maybe
because I know part of that family
smokes
there you go hmm
[Music]
I heard you got that [__] fire
see I heard you guys to do that does
that marijuana stuff you guys have been
laying around that's what an old man
should do you know if you got some extra
that's what you're supposed to do as an
old man and the old man will always get
nugs
because you always ever you always want
everyone wants to see an old man get
high it's just a fact like oh
even it's like a 40 year old a 30 year
old guy could be smoking a joint all
stupid and they'll get 900 comments like
dancing was small I don't even inhaling
a seven-year-old Man hitting a joint
[Music]
even if he doesn't know he's what he's
yeah damn I damn near I faked spit don't
worry about it
yeah so anyway that's what happened this
weekend so Shay Lynn W no I don't fear
that I used to fear the conversation to
a getting judge now the getting judge is
more of like
oh bro
if you think it's just weed
you're dumb
do a lot more than just smoke weed on
the internet I say that because that's
the way I like to say it because it's
funny what do you do if you want to
smoke weed on the internet I'll do [__]
else because because I used to cut the
conversation nobody would ask me
anything else after that that's why I
like to say it I just smoke weed there's
a clip on me on Tick Tock people tag me
in it all the time the guy that walks
around what do you do for a living you
bought this from this place and then the
guy who comes with me hey man like your
stuff what'd you do
smoke weed on the internet man walked
off but in real time he kept recording
goes for real that's what you're doing
yeah he goes oh it's sick but he didn't
put that in there little [__]
he's put in like a recording the
internet and I left but I just did that
so he would not talk to me anymore like
no I don't want to talk I don't want to
talk but now it's more like that's like
the most intriguing thing you can say
though
you're right you're right you're right
but I say that to stop the conversation
because most people like what if I can
live there
that's what most people think you just
get a high online what a loser like the
whole thing you just play video games
yeah those are millionaires now you know
like this Gamers they're millionaires
same [__] so I just saying so people
stop talking to me now it's more like oh
we do a company I know I do this but
yeah yeah oh what's it called here check
it out I've never done that I don't do
that to people ever so I'm like y'all
just stop talking to me I don't talk we
talked about this last time but I've
gotten over that so yeah old man yes
that is me that does marijuana stuff
whatever
when you're gonna say Old Timer anyway
that's the question
shout out to [__] Shaylin W
yeah up next 6p Michael are you ready
good question how much do you how much
do you spend on weed and concentrates
and shrooms in one month I want to hear
that chat that answered in the cast
why can't I read today
wait stop and then underneath your sink
because there's double screens you guys
can't see it doesn't want to kill white
women
laughs
it's part of my airplane [__] but it
looks like it's on the notes I want to
hear the answer the cast doesn't want to
kill white women
okay sorry
Marty
when you were in your days of buying on
the deliveries all day how much were you
spending for real
because you're buying a little eights
and [__] out of time yeah I was
literally just buying ace at a time
which is the stupidest [__] thing you
can do like just you can power Smash
Bowls though yeah probably like an
eighth a day damn near
but delivery charges
they love this guy they love him
50 minimum
because like I never spend lump sums on
weed I know because you always think
like I can't do it it's irresponsible
it's been a little every day
when he started doing cocaine yeah oh no
just get 20 every 40 minutes for six
hours like bro you spent 280 that's the
[__] worst
[__] that was me before I started
selling sacks we got a couple dogs we
got a couple more dogs 10 sack 10 sack
10 sack let's buy an eight I remember my
homie Anthony let's all throw our money
in just like we'll get an extra 0.5
good
a gram if we buy an eight
what about an a that was so hyped
yeah but shout out to cbx and [__] just
you for giving me a week because now
I've been so life is easier so we're
having a dryer [__] weed and not even
thinking worry about it so much easier
Christ come on it's so much easier
um
but the reason I did this because I I've
done the math
and it made me disgusted but like I
bought a pound right basically just say
three yeah three bands bought the pound
that 28.
that's 175 an ounce I believe
I was buying them for 300.
I saved half my money yeah that was only
buying a couple Zips here and there
every couple every week
just like you were doing with it but
every week because I was like I'm not
buying a QB that QB is [__] 1800 that
was ridiculous blah blah blah
but I'm over here spend 2600 in the same
week spread out yeah oh what an idiot
but it's okay it's okay that's what
happens when you don't sell packs no
more I know the math so I'm just like
you're getting me real good right now
[__] how much for the zip
the 800 on this P hmm
I don't sell no more do you think but
damn I'm buying zips
and then that's how that music plays
from the
on the animal commercials that's what
plays when it goes through my hand when
I pay for the week
as I'm standing handing money over it
and that plays I never and then like
Goodfellas I never thought I'd be on
this side of the the table I never
thought I'd be the one paying for their
asses
and that's when I knew I wanted to sell
packs again or whatever we do anyway
ready
if I go to a good clinic or dtpg or
whatever it is or my Hoagies bites cute
piece of fire different Growers
I probably
if I'm getting like ounce
like 1100 bucks every time I go probably
and they're hooking me up so sometimes
let's just say twelve hundred dollars
probably go every week
so that's what
4400 or no 4 800.
a month
but I also get hash
so that's like
another two or three bands
but also I make weak content
a lot of this weed a lot of this weed
right a lot of this weed is a
we smoke here we smoke with uh on the
lies uh we smoke with a hash on the
crazy video so like this is also like I
don't smoke if I spend 1100 I don't
smoke it all that week I just happen to
go get re-up in Rio because I'm getting
low but by the end of the month I'll
have like another couple ounces
but remember guys
it's not just me
and it's not every month I don't buy a
zip of hash every month you see how I
plow through these [__] joyfuls
goddamn [__] look at this spotless
um
I don't buy hash that much like that no
I don't fly through hash like that this
is say it's one month and I'm reading up
[__] fat that's the most I spent
that's the most I'll spend
because if I buy a pound it's cheaper
than that 4 800 for the month and I get
a pound way more than I was buying but
it's one flavor
I like this flavor though so I'm down
with that so it's a disgusting amount of
money but also like
I still have some Zips from the week one
if I got four ounces
five ounces
I don't kill that in a week
maybe I smoke too so then I re-up that
next 1200 and I got another it's not
like two bottoming out no no I'm not
bottoming out and smoking all of it like
damn boy you say you spend seven
thousand dollars all week in a month
what the [__] wrong with you like this
like there's no way I would allow myself
to spend 96k in a year on weed that is
the dumbest [__] I've ever heard
ever but remember people give me give me
times and times ten of the month of the
weed I buy people give me weed all the
time
because if companies like yo here here I
usually give it to other people
not all the time I'll smoke some of it
if it's really fire but I usually just
give it to other people man because I
know exactly what I want to smoke I
bought those Zips because of that reason
and plus I'm giving this my homies my
homies don't give my weed and [__] like
it helps it's dope
but
that's how I think about it like if I'm
ringing up the fattest ever
that's about what I would spend but
that's throughout the month if I just
re-up and got a pound cut in half
literally cut the price in half and I
can sit on that pound and I can sit in
jars I'll have it for the next month
probably because I got different flaves
which you would always do if you could
find what you wanted 100 I would spend
that and like yo that's how much
thousands of dollars but thousands of
dollars when it's my profession my hobby
the weed I smoke all day I'm with
friends we're on the show we got fat
joints for the guests dude we if we have
four guests we're smoking five ounces
almost
because we today I wrote at least four
at least
15 grams
of what we smoked today which sounds
wild no no no no no no no those two fat
ones were three grams each so six grams
seven eight ten baby this one 13 grams
at most 12 grams
but
if I'm getting off in the clinic or the
the spots
I was like [__] four dollars hmm for
different you know different I don't
know 400 it's like 300 some halves are
200 some of the Zips are 450. so it's
like it's Boutique [__] though like you
know the [__] is fire as hell but I was
reading on the planet Ben's Boutique as
hell
and also guys this is just high-end weed
I could be getting this [__] for a half
yeah if I was like yo this week's good
not like it's a 9.5 yeah this is nines
and ten so I'm like oh hell yeah
I could be spending even a quarter but
also this is a profession this is what I
do we do this [__] we smoke me and Rosie
smoke a lot
I don't go out to Club I don't do that
kind of stuff so people that would spend
the money on that and do vacation [__]
like I'm responding let's smoke some
weed
I give weed to people a lot of the times
too so you gotta remember that like a
lot of this weed is gone I'm not smoking
all of it all the time a lot
a lot of people yeah I give a weed a lot
of people so
makes me disgusted but also at the same
time as a business expense in my head
like yo I have to this is what I do even
uh Jesus dude
oh geez he's bodyguard oh he uh oh how
much weed I gave these people when they
left because he didn't smoke he's like
hey man you got you got some more joints
Mike I don't have anything rolled but I
got some jars and I gave him hella cbx I
gave him and his DJ hella CPX and again
hella dopest sharks uh chocolate bars
some pans and syrups and I gave him
hella syrups
yeah they're gonna be high for a minute
yeah but see like we have a lot of this
like just
because like spread it around like oh
yeah you need some weed type [__] it
depends it depends on who you know what
I mean I might just like my homie asked
me for weed every two days like bro no
I'm gonna wait for you bro he asked me
every two days go get some weed
I did that for six years straight since
it's a year seven I'm not saying my
friends do that but if there is like
that's the time I'm like no I'm gonna
wake sure what the [__]
um but yeah that's that that's the the
weed thing
but also remember
if you're like a car mechanic like how
much you spend on [__] oil like a lot
actually but it's kind of for my
business though I need that like yeah me
too
small I do weed [__] you'd be a [__]
fraud if you weren't going for the bus
we'd you could
and that's that come on
yeah you'd not be
the top we do it on Earth
not be doing it just us yeah also I've
decided to like we talked about filming
my phone I'm just gonna start recording
[__] on my phone
there'll be some times where I'm smoking
doing the craziest like dude this is a
crazy scene like
this is Grand Theft Auto wow and I wish
I was filming this that's what I say all
the time because I don't have my
videographer I'm not miked up I'm like
oh my God I feel I'm just gonna sound
bad
I'm on your phone
all my YouTube videos just be phone
videos until I got it until until like
2018.
just film my phone and getting the
moment go watch the baked three episode
go watch what is it was it living in
Grand Theft Auto 6. baked on the
dopasiola channel long ass blog but at
the end I gave you so many phone clips
and Marty made the sickest Montage ever
with it
so damn tight and that was all just
phone Clips so I got to start filming on
my phone again this is what I did today
real quick guys I'm gonna show you
I did this with John adamill earlier and
we wouldn't have this if I didn't decide
start filming on my phone again
if you can see that
that's the HotBox
I HotBox my sauna today with a weed gun
from the Travis Thompson episode
we'll overlay it but so ridiculous we
wouldn't have that if I didn't go start
filming my phone again who cares because
we only have a Nikita filming outside we
wouldn't get the POV the inside I gotta
start doing that again
so
um yeah I gotta do more I'm going to buy
weed
tell me real quick buy so many different
strains and fun stuff and take dads with
people or smoke with random ass fools
that people like oh you chill with them
like yeah
but I don't want to bike yo I'm gonna go
smoke can I remember my videographer to
smoke with like
I was supposed to have a phone clip I
smoke that [__] here just it's just fun
stuff it's kind of like a vlog through
life
if I showed everything we do we'd have
so much more content and we do so [__]
how many times we do can we believe this
how many times we were just sitting here
like this is
who's the sick-ass interview this
supposed to die and then we're sitting
there smoking and go wow
we need somebody to film this BTS [__]
then we say I'm like I'm just gonna film
myself on my phone that's how I started
and so we're gonna I gotta go back to
that filming everything so
yeah [__] yeah
done that was the fan questions thank
you very much thank you Jesus how long
you been here two okay I feel bad when
we don't get to hit the fan questions
uh sometimes we can't get to them in
guest episodes so yeah that's everybody
it is hard drops the questions the fan
questions sometimes it's hard to fit
into especially like Jeezy at 59 minutes
and 59 seconds I looked at it
because
as we were talking this manager told us
before like we have one hour in the dot
then they have to go to the next
interview I'm like perfect we can do
that
I was talking we're in the conversation
and his manager peeked through the door
and went
and I went if you see me in one thing I
went
and I looked back it said 59 minutes and
59 seconds when this is precise I
couldn't believe it when I saw that
wow that was incredible
that's amazing but you know I forgot
what that I was so blacked out I didn't
even see you I was so blacked out
thinking of songs Marty I was so blacked
out
sure I was just lost do you see the the
photos of us we were so just locked in
just listening to this man just like the
show was just crazy
it's all so cool Soto so epic
um I forgot why we even talked about the
cheesy thing right now and I said that
we were talking about it and I talked
about his manager and then my brain went
give him the weed giving the weed was
that it I think so probably not we'll
know in the chat when we watch this
episode
oh I'll know Marty's gonna rain no you
edited the damn thing
um yeah okay
let's let's let's move let's move oh
also the Travis Thompson episode that
was fun thank you guys very much for
that he's awesome wore the push tree's
gear in his show the next day oh no two
days later because the next day he came
over my house so he got high as hell
I'm like bro just hit me up come chill
yes we did the next day he came over my
house we got high as hell he chilled me
and Route suck
it was awesome
gave him some gear that full war on his
on stage the next day
not like I was giving like please wear a
juice show I was just like yo here's
some gear you weren't on your shoes the
first true shot on stage is cool
appreciate you man that's that's because
if I was going on stage I would be very
aware of what shirt I would wear on
stage yeah of course
so that was very cool of him and then
before that was FaZe Rain episode
um
FaZe Rain episode got Adrian real quick
so the travel stop so Travis Thompson I
saw the Jesus times another weird guy
that was a lot yeah we kind of knew that
one coming but the phase main one we
didn't really do too hard but it's all
good uh we're just going back talking
about the past episodes because we have
this one and then we're gonna go on a
tear
next week we got ad coming in I'm
excited yes next week is A.D
um you guys know ad has his own podcast
he's a podcast he's he used to be a no
jumper that obviously we're not gonna
get into that as a whole ordeal but uh
yeah we have him next week
we're supposed to be having Mexican tea
very soon
fluffy Cheech
supposed to be fight react so we're
gonna have a some stacked episodes oh
I can't wait for fluffy to get here and
go hey we look alike and people always
tell me you and people always call me
you all the time
all the time bro he's like yeah I can
see that I'm like yes
yes love is here it feels hilarious I'm
so excited dude and I hope he just gets
high because I'm Gonna Roll that's
that's another one the fans did all that
was was uh I commented on his post 600
fans lit that [__] comment up bam he
had no choice with the response no
that's how it went thank you guys now
yeah we're talking to his manager now
that [__] is happening I am excited so
we have a lot of guests coming up so
we just wanted to catch up with this
solo episode like always thank you guys
so much for being here we're not done
because I have something let's talk
about but we do have to get out of here
somewhat soon
damn it's 11 o'clock at night oh [__]
all right
all right basically someone oh my
schedule I was just talking about going
to bed and then you know getting up
early it's gonna be [__] that's
basically what he's thinking now
um here we go
hold on hold on real quick let me
worrying about something has anybody
ever heard about this [__] in their
school sports
tryouts for a sport a high school sport
oh two weeks left a summer vacation they
got my daughter going in from 7 to 9 30
in the morning and then back from 5 to 7
30 Monday through Friday for two weeks
on summer break
let that sink in we're talking about
four trips to the high school on summer
break for tryouts
for JV volleyball and then they also
said anyone that was on the team last
year doesn't have to try out they got
letters kids got letters before tryouts
saying they didn't have to try out
because they already made the team so
basically there's only a couple spots
for all these new girls what if the new
girls are better that was never a thing
that's not a thing that's like a
participation trophy it's three days two
days after school then there was a list
everybody had to get their heart broken
or not on that [__] list right like
he told me this is lame dude
yeah you can whine about that's fine
thank you has anybody else ever heard
any [__] like that before because I
don't think it sucks
another thing I want to whine about is
how do high schools get the pass on
stealing all these goddamn logos you
ever notice that oh you're right because
they're not monetizing wait they sell
them they sell the tickets they sell
everything I looked it up like it's just
something the answer doesn't press the
issue you're wrong
you guys got all these kids coming
through nobody can draw a goddamn logo
you got to steal the [__] NFL [__]
and the only art they ever put on the
side is the kid they could draw okay and
the face is always a little choppy you
ever noticed that there was like
George Washington like that's Prince
George Washington Road it's always a kid
that's like not the best and the quiet
kid in corn would have killed it but
it's always the girl like I am the art
student you're not that good
well you might be I don't know I need
some good artists but you know what I'm
talking about totally It's always a [__]
picture on the side of the building it's
the bus we got this is the best we could
do
this is our art Department
we're said we said I had a sick mural
though our art Department had a crazy
mural that was a cool picture of you
with the Maybach in front of the show oh
that that was a new building
I wear those Multicultural mural in size
six probably painted over but yeah I had
to go back I brought it back to Mercy
Mercy it
um talk about Marty for a second
I wrote this down I'm glad I did don't
read it don't read it don't read it
Mark Marty this guy right here maybe
Martin Lawrence
O'Neill
Martin Lawrence O'Neill to my right your
left or straight I don't know I was
chopped [__] name
is the manliest person on the Earth
and let me tell you why
gave Marty
manliest person on Earth
gave Marty hash pills
and I said hey Marty how'd you like
those hash pills
oh man they're good I've been cracking
them open and throwing them things in my
coffee every time Marty's hyped about
something's like got some of them things
t-h-a-n-g
always I mean would you say he's like
I've been cracking open the pills and
putting him into my coffee Marty's been
cracking open hash pills and throwing
him in the car you're not supposed to
crack them open bad idea right so I was
like Marty and then I watched Marty make
coffee once so many pills to take if
you're trying to actually cracks them
open instead he's like I want to get
high
instead of taking the pills
I get it hold on I'm gonna have to take
all 20 of these [__] pills so you're
gonna crack them open and put them in my
coffee is what he said
I wanted to get high so I chugged the
bong water and ate the bong after two
it's got resin on like what's wrong with
you
the manliest person on earth once again
I walked in on Marty and I was like yo
this with coffee this fool
I'm not lying
he put coffee beans in his mouth poured
hot water and just started shaking I am
lying I'm just kidding but the manliest
man on Earth he just coffee beans
hot water and he's like they drank it
you know the oil the oil had my mug
tasting like oil after I washed the [__]
it got stuck it was infused mug yeah the
pores was it porcelain mug yeah
um manliest man on the Earth
cracking hash pills and brewing coffee
in his teeth
insane I've seen hot water oh
[Music]
it was nuts
no creamer straight black call back
that was today
glad I remember Jesus Christ
um
damn I thought the [__] 12 grams was
enough we just flew through all that
[__] Jesus Christ let's look down for a
choice
oh man it's all right we've been here
for a little over two hours I'm Gonna
Leave You off with this
because I thought it was funny
ready story I think I told you this
you looked at me like you're about to
say some [__] wouldn't you I just
stopped
no I'm just I'm not there's gonna be
people in the comments that do [__] like
that with the coffee
Shake
all right I don't think so no I don't
think anybody cracking hash pills it was
a lot
this was cracking burrito size handfuls
of food episode two
when we had packets and things all those
things yeah
I was cutting them with the scissors I
was cutting them with a scissors
hi that's [__]
yeah so that's what Marty does he
[__] he puts the weed in his mouth
and likes it he don't give a [__] I just
chew the Nugget to my teeth
the stick
you would look like a monster doing that
could you imagine nug out and
about holding the Nugget and teeth and
snorting it oh my god oh that hot box
cleared this side of my nose today I
haven't breathed the left side of my
nose in like three years
damn shout out to the hot box man the
hot box came out with and coughed out
all this [__] and then went wait wait
no I didn't need it we and then John
decided to join so it was the worst it
was three people in that thing oh God it
was so hot he Tapped Out in 14 seconds
John just left
um Okay so story
his little Story Time slash just like
some [__] that happened
ready
here we go
shout out to GB we've had him on here GB
Ghetto Boy farmer said the artist from
Mercedes awesome on this episode yeah
thank you sir let's wear with us
so is the Penguin Skittles right Pink
Starburst sir sir
this is bone dry oh my God
there is nothing in this Marty
you
yo I've [__] with the white widow I
didn't realize that shirt was empty
though Marty
oh it is yeah it is
easy I've been ripping the [__] I don't
think I've ever seen anybody clear
clear one out this is like a like a like
a hollow coconut like it's a rare
occasion nobody gets it all you got it
all
[__] are you talking about
Merced [__] sorry hold on we got this is
from peace for history
this is science there is nothing in here
Marty I I couldn't have got it cleaner
if I never filled it
yo that [__] white widow is fine oh
my God
oh it's that one okay all right I got
you
which one is this Starburst uh yeah
that [__] is [__] fire too
I tried out the uh yeah it is what is it
the apple pie the new Apple one red one
and the Apple yeah
openshop.com
that one's bomb all right
GB damn I haven't drank a sip of water
see I ain't lying when I say I was a
display
oh rip this smoke 12 Grand
I have a drink one sip of water since we
sat here the 40 gram joint didn't drink
a drop I should have why didn't I
didn't
hear like a half cap full
I didn't travel
I Squidward bit that [__] are you ready
shout out to GB during the episode he's
like yo I do give backs to the park do
all the [__] man I go shut the [__] up
for real that's why we did the meet and
greet at the Shoe Store in Merced
and that's why we did the meet and
greets for dopest all over the country
is the shoe store still cracking they
got a bigger spot even bigger on Main
Street nice like a fat one they left and
went to a big spouse fast yeah I was
sick
um
we did that right GB hit me up like in
June says hey we're doing a call give
back at the park at McNamara Park uh if
you want to sponsor something sponsor
something I'm like yo this is the budget
he goes no that's
it's not it's a lot I was like no that's
the budget I wanted to do so I was like
yo paper and he's like that's gonna be a
lot left over and you know put it toward
whatever it's from push tree I'm like
bro it's [__] I really give it to you
guys right now then like I have to pay
probably pay taxes if I could the
government like bro hell no
even if it doesn't work that way it's
like
if we can do one thing like a year like
yo boom yeah that's dope right and it's
Merced so I'm like full I don't like
whatever you need bam
I was hyped about it
and it feels cool like no
use it right like cool good [__] as
Merced I felt so awesome like I'm a
hyped to do something for Merced so this
is what happened it was it was called
get back in the park to get in you have
to bring one brand new toy
that's the thing there's a bunch of
booths there's artist La Russell played
we've had the Russell on the show before
um a baby gas played a bunch of other
Bay Area and Central Valley artist came
it was dope at McNamara Park I've talked
about McNamara Park I've talked about
this in Story Time my grandma owns the
apartments that touched back mirror park
in the back my grandpa when my grandpa
chased that guy with the machete was
right there
all the craziest [__]
is McNamara Park 12th Street we've
talked about the story time that just
came out
12th Street it's right there it's the
it's where I grew up I grew up five
blocks away it's just the kind of ghetto
they have fixed it up since GB and all
them been there or whatever happened but
they had made the park incredible it
looks like a different place I didn't
even recognize the park I went this
wasn't here but there's an astro turf
field
there's a skate park
anyway uh
we go there and then anyway he tells me
he's like yo if you could show up that'd
be sick I'm like all right yeah I'll be
there no matter what
and then you know we post it people are
hyped
bring a new toy and all the toys are
going to Valley Children's Hospital
that's the thing is like a big toy drive
of course let's do that [__]
I get there we pull up I walk in
10 steps
and then that's it first fan like yo man
I'm a big big fan like hell yeah
I'm not saying I'm loud but like I'm
hyped like I'm genuinely like sick
and then you know another person comes
another person it turned into a meet and
greet it turned to a meet and greet line
in four seconds
so
I was right by a tree turned into a meet
and greet line which I'm stoked for like
that's that's perfect bring as many
people did you bring a toy good [__]
thank you for bringing some [__] for the
kids all that right like that's what
we're here for I'm hype I'll do a meet
and greet right now
I do this year for four hours straight
four and a half hours straight didn't
leave that spot
stood right there for four and a half
hours met a bunch of fans it was awesome
met a bunch of fans do like a lot of
people in Merced
and I always says where are you from I
was like what part of her set are you
from so that's why I asked because we're
all in Merced some people grew up right
down the street from me one dude here I
think I told you this Marty
two dudes walking Mexican a white
looking kid Mexican kid I'm like yo
thank you so much following is all hyped
up and his homie is within the wider
looking kid he starts talking to me
and he's like yo you know my mom
yo
for real remember guys
it's Merced a lot of people I know
started having kids at 15 14.
and I'm 33 now I feel like that's a
weird to say out loud but I'm not 22
anymore which is crazy
but some people I know have 20 year old
children now 19 year old kids people I
went to Tanaya with and should have you
know
kids that can almost drink and I know it
sounds crazy because I don't look 30 but
I am in my 30s right
kid goes you know my mom I go what's
your mom's name
like you know my mom that means that
lady told your mom told you that she
knows me
and if she's gonna say that she probably
really does know me I don't know you
know I mean I never like chill with that
many people
he says her name and I couldn't believe
I didn't notice that that wasn't her kid
the second he walked the second he said
like oh my God you look like just like
your mom I know exactly here like the
second he said like what
and then you know what I remember guys
the last time I saw this guy's mom
I was going to hang out with her to
smoke I went over her house I went to
the meter at the park to smoke We Were
Young so I was like
we're still you know we probably
couldn't even drink and I was going to
smoke weed with her at the park and I
was like I got there and go
oh there's a kid
not like one of those dudes oh what's up
girl oh you brought your kid no I don't
smoke around children I don't want to
smoke around kids I don't want to put
that on there
it's not their choice right
that was the same kid
that's telling me hey you know my mind
went oh my God you're the little kid
from the park that's all I thought oh I
remember you you were on the playground
I was like are you sure like if he comes
over here I'm just gonna walk away he's
like it's fine
like whatever you do for your kid that's
fine I'm not smoking around your child a
little Swisher
also smoking blunts we started smoking
got like halfway he came running over
and I was like ah and I walked to the
sidewalk and he looked at me I was like
I'm so sorry and he ran back to the
parts 50 yards away it's not like we're
blowing smoke in this kid's face at all
because I was like nah I'm good
so last time I saw her I haven't seen
her since
and I haven't seen that Lord and now
that kid's just watching my [__]
videos going to the damn meet and greet
to the park
I couldn't believe my eyes because I
mean we're a kid and she already had a
five-year-old child like we were
We Were Young so
it's just odd right anyway do the meet
and greet everything's going great my
dad my stepmom all my brothers and
sisters my cousins show up but everybody
shows up dude and it was cool there was
boost the Merced Unified
uh Sports League thing was for soccer
was there
I was doing something in Merced in the
park that we're not allowed to go to
when I was a kid because it's ghetto as
hell but I still went my grandma I live
right now we're right next door I was
painting over
[__] dead bugs and and and and Nails
ghetto apartment [__] like bugs that are
squished forever you can't even scrape
them like paint over it bro
gross we're in the ghetto I was painting
my grandma's apartments for since I was
a child painting over Nails knock them
in real quick because I don't want to
take it out come on this school's gonna
live here for two weeks it's a ghetto
ass apartment complex people get kicked
out all the time and plus I was nine
like Grandma I don't want to paint this
sorry if I sound lazy I was just like
damn dude
anyway painting the ceilings as a kid
sucks because as you get as you do the
roller it sprays and it gets your eyes
and it burns
anyway
off topic thanks Mom acid
um
meet and greet everything's going good
everything's going good in my whole
family blah blah they're all walking
around I didn't get to see anybody hey
what's up as I'm in a meet and greet
line long ass line it just didn't stop
which was awesome
right but I was like yo the Merced
Unified sports league is at a place that
we're doing an event for that like we're
part of this is insane like
can't believe like this is the most
positive [__] I've ever done in my life
that's I just kept thinking like this is
so sick story now I'll start
everything's going uh good everything's
going great and then some guy I mean a
fan is taking a picture with me and I
don't see the dude's face he's tall with
a beard I'm assuming it's his dad the
guy looks the guy I said the kid looks
probably like 18 17.
all right the dude's holding the phone
moves the phone I look at him like
do I know you
and he says his name like whoa
I went to deny with you
this is your kid I just took a picture
with
whoa and I was like no I didn't get
older I'm still the same age when I came
I forgot everyone had kids when they're
young and this dude was like six three
so this kid was big so he looked even
bigger like this is your child
you had him we were in high school
whoa
he was like yeah man and he looked at
this because I've told you so it's
because I was like yeah right there you
went to school with this fool yeah right
he'll know you I was like oh and I said
and he said I'm like oh I used to call
him something I want to say his name but
I was like so-and-so with the spiky air
because there's not there's like a bunch
of dudes in the same name like the whole
one with the spiky hair that guy you
know you say uh Kevin no tall Kevin no
buff Kevin
short ass Kevin you we all have those
terms he was so-and-so with the spiky
hair and I said it I'm like damn full
and I looked at like are we getting
always like I just had him in high
school yeah but I'm right now
probably a little too I just don't look
like it I don't have any children maybe
maybe that's what helped that was a
little younger and I smoke a lot of weed
for the living I'm not really stressed
except for my own [__] up so not going
to sleep on time anyway
that happened two times and I went oh my
God bro I haven't seen you forever this
is your kid hey nice to meet you man I
remember when this Flash
and uh I snuck off after the line
stopped I snuck off at like hours six or
five and it went out to my car I started
smoking a joint and there was a fan
dabbing I just gave him like a bunch of
hat like broke stab all that [__] and
it's just fun when people are like
yo nice to meet you my oh you want dab
yeah like yeah take that [__] and we're
all just smoking in a circle I just I
feel like it's like yo these fools gonna
be hyped watch our [__] let's take it
here dab this [__] because everybody
want to take [__] rips with me inside
my bro I'm sorry this is a kid's thing I
can't really smoke inside the park like
that there's my little brothers right
there I can't take a blinker but I can't
like I'm inside the [__] charity
event maybe maybe outside be outside in
the parking lot if you see me outside in
the parking lot I'll rip with you anyway
smoking a joint and I see down the
street like
60 yards right
yeah like like a little more half
football field I see this dude and
another guy get out of the car
obviously the kid's younger and the guy
with the beard is a little older he's a
huge beard and as he sits gets out he's
far and I just see his face and he has a
huge beard and I just remember seeing
this part of his face and I went
damn that looks like this full name Josh
that sold me the first fire weed I ever
had
like I was buying weed from people
trying this trying that and this guy
named Josh on Oleander Street where
um
right down the street from we used to be
George Brown GB3 Paul's Place right
there in Oleander Merced
I remember the day he sold me fire first
time I seen like fire fire like Boutique
in the 10th grade I went
whoa this is this is a fire I didn't
even say fire I wasn't even a tournament
I'm like this is bomb ass wheat
so this is dank as hell
probably dang I say dig all the time I
was a kid
and uh
and I remember like wow that guy Josh
has [__] fire never saw him again
he got kicked out of our school and had
to go to like the continuation school I
think I don't want to put that out there
and say you did but I think that's what
happened
I remember him like going to another
school after being with our school
I don't want to speak out and be like
bro I never gotten kicked out what are
you saying that my kid watches your [__]
sorry if I messed that up I just
remember you're not going to our school
anymore and everybody that left our
school I assume goes to Valley and or
east campus Because you get in trouble
right never saw him again
guy gets out starts walking on the
sidewalk
smoke would enjoy it gets like 20 yards
I just start walking toward him like I'm
gonna ask like it was your name Josh
and I'm walking like yo hey man he goes
what's up is your name Josh I asked him
he's a huge beard long hair did not look
a day like he did when we were kids
and he goes yeah man Thomas how you
doing oh Josh
also from only industry he goes see he
looks at the guys I told you
so he's like I'm like is this your kid
he goes yeah he's like I had him in 10th
Grade like after we after I was like
after we saw we were hanging out like
whoa
like this is your son he's a family took
a picture or whatever I think we took a
picture
but I'm talking I'm like dude you're the
first person to ever sell me fire we
just like want to say that in front of
the camera of course
he'll just get like yep like yeah Josh
and as I saw him like there's no way
that's you I haven't seen you since I
was 15 years old and you're just gonna
pop up because he was going to the event
his kid watch is heavy he's like we
watch his stuff man I always tell him
like so we that guy when we were in
Congress yeah right you so we to him
like that's the first guy to ever sell
me fire I remember the nugs remember
what they look like like whoa what is
that that's a High Times magazine we're
back when High Times was a [__] as I
said you was seeing magazines and see
like Chong on the cover like
Baker bongs whoa Jerome Baker like it
was Jack Herer right up when it was like
magazine now she's like a bunch of [__]
right random weed now just like good
weed yeah back then I had never seen it
anyway I saw him uh the event's cool do
the whole event awesome right
after the event
right after the event
I'm like dude I'm gonna drive by Merced
I mean I remember said we're driving my
Grandma's house my grandma dolores's
house I keep telling you guys I want to
buy that house and it was up for
sale when I did not have the money to
buy that
someone snatch it up
so I'm like you know what I bet you if I
make him an offer will take it if I'm
like no no I'll bring cash and I'll buy
it for that price if you can do cash and
I will have you know what I mean like I
want this house the reason I want my
grandma's house is so I can
we should do Christmas at my grandma's
everybody in my family comes my grandma
to do Christmas there right
but we don't have that anymore
it's it's not the same right my grandma
died my grandma died so different
but if I can be in that house I feel
like wow we're back at Grandma's house
for Christmas oh [__] I think I'd just
be hyped you know you need to be able to
like Butterfly Effect myself back into
[__] Grandma's house
so what I want to do is build a nicer
modern house in the backyard the
backyard's massive I want to build a
modern like two-bedroom
and we can all be living staying there
three bedrooms stay in there during
Christmas coming to town and go all
right let's go do presents and walk
through
to the old Grandma's house
and do Christmas inside it's a pretty
sick idea it's [__] incredible that's
a blank check [__] that's some [__] I
would like she had a tear over
I gotta put the nasty ass yellow
linoleum back though because that's
going to make it pop they changed it I
want to Zillow and walk through my
grandma's house on Zillow it was weird
they changed it all inside
I'm looking like yeah he's a sack of
weed right there wow he's just more
casual right there I had many
Christmases there that's how I learned
how to play [__] rummy and that's why
I [__] fixed this and that's where my
[__] Aunt fell on the throw up it was
me and John used to Coco all over that
[__] right there this is just brought
back so many memories and uh
so I'm like [__] it I'm in the Maybach
too
anyway I wore my other watch because I
was like you know I'm gonna do some [__]
like it looks sick
so obviously I look like it's kind of
like a dick like this damn Jesus Christ
what the [__] that's how I feel people
feel you know [__] them never mind [__]
a dick thing I pull up in the [__] I had
and I was in pulled in my car I parked
right in front of the house
and there's an old man on the lawn I'm
like oh my God someone's finally outside
this is the day so I pull up and I park
and then next door neighbors from the
story time uh remember uh girl Jerry
Geraldine that I used to smoke weed with
and her mom thought I was banging her
and my grandpa thought I banged her she
was like yeah you had a party huh her
mom came by good job hey guy that story
that neighbor that's the house I saw two
dudes outside and I saw old man outside
of my grandma's and I pull out and right
when I get out I I flip a [__] at the
corner and there's like a family on the
corner uh outside their house on the
other side of Mr Edwards so my homie
Russell and his sister Danielle used to
live there so I'm like damn they don't
live there no more wild there's like
generational houses you know I mean
their grandma died and they passed the
mom and everybody moved same thing with
the whole block it's just weird to see
it now like wow someone lives in
Danielle's house and Russell weird
Park
I get out to talk to old man doesn't
speak English at all like
uh how do you live here you just looked
at me
like come on man help me yes sir is this
your house
not aware of my I like the fence they
put a little fence I like that and I was
talking to him like I like that oh you
did a great I was just like wow you
fixed the you fixed the garage my
grandpa never fixed it she was broken
you had to hold it up while you just ran
in anyway
and the guy next door is a younger dude
came next door from Mexico he's like 20s
like in his 20s he's like hey can I help
you I'm like yeah I just want to know if
you listen yeah he didn't speak English
but I can help out so I'm like oh thank
you dude like so I used to live in this
house I would like to buy this house if
he's willing to sell it that's all I
wanted to know if you're willing to sell
it I would love to buy it and he said it
to him in Spanish which I need to learn
Spanish because this would have went
over a lot nicer his [__] in this car
watch can't even speak Spanish he used
to live here yeah right [__] you that's
probably what he was going through with
his he had to just rake he's
um probably should approached it better
Ralph wasn't me speaks fluent Spanish
Sharon get out with me
anyway
um
and he tells the guy and he goes oh he
says the sun house his son owns it he
can't really say yes or no but he'll ask
his son
and I talked to the guy I'm like so yeah
I was
um can you take my number down as I do
that the dudes from the corner the dude
from the Corner House walked over and
he's just like that
yeah what's up man and I automatically
went into like mode of when I need a fan
I'm Juiced when someone's like enough to
go hey man are you yeah I follow your
[__] like hey thank you [__] Yeah so I
would just hyped
I'm in the middle of conversation with
about to give my number go what's that
anyway are you done with you and I walk
on my on one second please and I go talk
to the full for like five minutes about
he's talking about this story time and
like this one was Ella's saying like bro
thank you talking about I'm like you I'm
Danielle and Russell used to live here
he's like oh yeah we moved here I'm like
yeah man I used to be in that house
every day playing games that was my
homie's house he's like bro what I knew
you lived on this block but I didn't
realize it was there I'm like this is
the house bro and I was in my head I'm
like there's only one she he school
there's like one Church like yeah is it
the house I'm talking about like wow I
never knew I was right here by this out
I'm like bro this is the house I grew up
and I talk about every single video you
live right here next to it he's like
what
wow you know you might even like get a
picture I'm like yeah of course I took a
picture with him we just talked for a
couple minutes and I turn around now the
Fool's like
what do you do what is this that's these
phrasing like what are you what are you
doing what do you what do you do
although I just make videos and stuff
and he's like oh okay he's like so you
used to live here I'm like yeah he said
grew up here he goes oh and he looked
over and he looks at the car and goes
what do you do what are you doing
something else you know yeah I just
moved away man doing Andrew's videos
it's kept very vague I used to sell
drugs and I would buy your house like
nah right anyways the next door neighbor
the kid that roundhouse kicked me in the
face we're gonna
um this is it we have to close out this
episode because it it's getting late
um
so I give him my number
start driving away I look at the stairs
I was like yeah it looks it looks so
much better that I'm gonna change it
back
at least you fixed a lot of [__] looks
great I'm gonna get that house one day I
want it so bad what was his answer here
we go a drive away I'm not even to the
freeway yet four minutes later the dude
from next door text me and goes bro what
the hell
it's like you're the same guy I'm like
what
so he goes on to text me and goes
Geraldine that girl I'm married to her
little sister Jackie I go Jackie little
Jackie because I remember her little
sister she was too young to be smoking
but she was like
what are you guys doing uh you're like
two years too young I can't be smoking
with your sister but they smoke together
with their sisters
like you're married to Jackie for real
like no way and he's like we always I'm
like so you're Thomas I'm like yeah he
goes damn dude they told me hella
stories about you go what you're like
this is her house
the next door neighbor gave it to this
daughter when she got married to that
guy
so that's their house and they told
stories about the next door neighbor
because the mom hates me indulges so
they've been she still brings it up of
like
Jerry and Jackie like this used to be a
guy named Thomas the next story Soul
weed he was hell he's like I've heard
hella stories about you I'm like for
real he's like yeah you're the guy
Thomas next door gets high as [__] wow
my highness ghost knows no bounds like
you knew me he didn't even know me he's
like oh I just looked up your YouTube
like
you're the same person and he like
connected he's like that's you're from
Merced I'm like yeah I do YouTube's like
your time oh man like what are the odds
of like connecting's like wow I'm like
so how's geraldine's like she's married
she's got three kids I always said I
wonder what happened she's got three
kids she's married she lives on this
side like wow Jerry grew up
like just like how [__] cool and he
goes oh by the way he said he don't want
to sell the house I'm like you
[__] I was so hyped about the
story he's like yeah Jerry's like they
still they they talked about you like
the guy from next door used to live here
like wow
who is reaching over the fence the first
time I ever met her she's like hey
what's up I was just smoking hey
I smoke I'm like that fence was four
feet high I'm like all right here and we
just I made a friend every night Rock A
Little Rock
out of her like a snake she'd just fall
off hands for or feet for crawl out of
her windows
if we'd walk where the light was it
would smoke balls
or a blunt when Swisher minis came out
we'd smoke one I see him
I sneak back into my grandma's house
and uh yeah how crazy like years later
oh he's married to Jack the little the
little sister it's a trip dude I just
thought it was like you've heard of me
already
amazing I get high and then [__]
um yeah so he's like yeah by the way you
say he doesn't want to sell the house
like oh
I was really Juiced when you led with
you're Thomas like oh so this is gonna
work anyways just great to hear the
story like I couldn't be more stoked to
hear that there's oh Jerry she's doing
good like
how cool man I was my homie through high
school never knew what happened to her
that's awesome man it was very cool
um yeah and that was it we're back to my
mom's house I didn't know one [__]
neighbor they're all gone different I
never knew him in the first [__]
I'm realizing this is
right there well next door Mr Edwards my
grandpa's best homie
and the other side was Daniel and
Russell the kids my age we played video
games in football
there's only four houses in the block
five house on the Block yeah and then it
turns to the school and then a church so
it's very he's like and then across the
street here's my block Church Park
Armory School
you know only a couple neighbors and a
lady with a German Shepherd I try to run
by real quick because it's scary
but uh yeah dude what is what a what a
turn of events in Merced how awesome was
that
so crazy so crazy it was so cool though
shout out to the [__] dude like it
made my day like as I'm in front of the
house trying to like I would like to buy
yeah like
perfect if this was making a deal I
think we if I was trying to get a record
deal I think you just sealed it from a
man but this is like
I want them to not be like Oh I'm a tax
this guy yeah I should have rolled up in
like a work truck hey man I would like
to buy this house
or favor my fully one little Taco Bell
taco over this all right because I'm a I
go to Maria's Tacos I mean a Victoria's
Taco Shop Merced is not the same and
then I posted it like yo what's up with
this burrito wasn't that great like yo
Maria's is this [__] so I'm only talking
about places only people from Merced no
I heard Maria's is back up on it uh
Victoria used to be Betos burritos and
it was the [__] when I was a kid
so anyway I only say Taco Bell because
it's the only consistent thing like yo
it's gonna be shitty every time but okay
perfect that's true because sometimes
I'll go to Mario's in Merced and like
that burritos bomb next time I remember
it was okay
and we'll get recipes man
I feel yeah I like that chipotle I
should have kind of Hit or Miss Chipotle
disgusting it might be amazing yeah I
don't trust Chipotle at McDonald's
they're Affiliated I don't trust
McDonald's
I'll be trusting the golden arches guys
we just ranted and rambled we're through
2 45.
yo see this is what happens didn't he
now it's 12. am I gonna eat and stay up
till two and three in the morning
or just go to bed like a pilgrim that's
starving like damn it dude I don't want
to look around a lot I'm smoking all
this weed
and I haven't gone grocery shopping yet
because I want I got a new fridge in the
in the garage so I can fill it with
fruits we got these baskets that you
chop all your fruit and stays fresh or
hella longer on these glass little
plastic things we got extra fridge just
for to live better
and then he said that well no I'll just
do real estate
so I want to wake up earlier and get
into real estate because of this man
look at for real for real though truly I
want to wow because the reason his album
is called thug motivation bro come on I
love that I love when you said I heard
there was this recession so I put out
the tape to warn all my people
um
mm-hmm that was the craziest thought
I've ever heard
artistically put it out there for people
to listen and people that and break it
down go oh there's a storm coming we
should probably get tightened up
that's some [__] I'll just let you know
if the pack prices are going up then I
guess I don't know what else to warn you
guys about it's your outcome
it's trout coming rules like the
Terminator there's a storm coming at the
end of it there's a drought coming
bids bids are coming in for the high yo
I touched my ioe it's officially over
this is over and it's so late and I'm
stuck guys why do we do this so late
it's okay oh I did the hot box where I
came over here that's why I feel so
tired [__] hot books we did 20 grams
in that [__] in two and a half minutes
and then the second we were done the bug
guy came by to spray and I was airing it
out and then he knocked on my glass door
he goes
is this open you want to spray in there
and go no you don't wanna go in there
just spray around it and I close the
door like this was gonna get [__]
contact high from the fumes and the
fumes from the [__] weed and there
was work the construction workers right
in eyesight across from me in backyards
I can see them as we're [__]
and looking at these guys like don't
look up bro unless you give a [__] but
it's all on the video cool if there was
a bug in there you'd be [__] oh bug in
the in the oh
behind a little lizard or something in
there I have an idea about it I mean I
like animals and bugs I don't want to
hurt them but I have a great idea and I
don't want to give it away because
somebody will do it but I have a very
awesome idea weed related things we'll
see we'll see
I don't know guys thank you so much for
being here my eye is on its way out I
touched it with the weed should I washed
my hands after it rolled because it's
definitely
it's starting to become a traditional in
several episodes around this time
that hurts okay Marty thank you for
thank you for listening to me talk about
you know stupid [__]
I'm here to give advice on how to use
your hash oils and how to yeah juice
things like that so I'm glad we made
that happen and you're you're living
vicariously through funny
pushing the boundaries jokes because you
can't say anything apparently I can't
say anything that's my favorite part of
the episode that's what's going to be
called Mario like this I can't say
anything the title that's it
with red and blue lights that's a good
one
guys
um this episode has been a whole a whole
lot of in between I have no idea oh my
God racist realization that was this one
sometimes I say [__] that I'm like but
also like it's funny to me
hey Power Rangers of racism jokes what
do you want to say I didn't say anything
I can't say
technically don't come at me because
I'll come at you as as a woke person
then
how are you gonna tell
the person what they can and can't say
about us
real quick I could be multiculturally
offended and be a piece of [__] if I
really want to
a little Jewish kid rolling away in the
German car I'll be an [__] real quick
you just wait a little brown kid I can't
speak Spanish
it was a bunch of weird [__]
it's so stupid guys most weed for living
[__] allergic
that's
it's looking true
it's like oxymoron [__]
it is the whole life and I don't like
Oxycontin it didn't work on me
isn't that all in that odd oxymoron and
oxy doesn't work I tried it when I was a
kid and didn't work do one thing I'm not
saying it doesn't work now it might it
didn't do anything
um
oh last thing I'll leave you with I'm
trying I tried to buy a different house
in Merced as I'm looking through the
pictures I realize you know whose house
it is as I realize it John the dealer
um what the [__] it's his house
his actual number the first time I ever
saw him besides with Ethan and Ryan I
was delivering a pizza and I told you
white blonde kid answer the door in the
summer with no shirt and a mink coat on
a mink coat fur
he had it he tried to sell it to me one
time with her friends a 20K bro like
what did you just say I drive a a a a
four thousand dollar car what are you
saying to me come on man it's really
sick like we live in 99 degree weather
going to buy minko this is not good
Fellas
anyway as I'm going through the pictures
on Zillow trying to talk to the realtor
I'm like this is John's the time where I
said where his homie broke and he almost
marked him went out tried to shoot him
on the lawn that whole thing so the
first time I met him I delivered a pizza
to him and he tipped me hella fat and I
remember like yo that's he's in Iran's
brother the fool that sells mad bags yo
he just tipped me off I had on one pizza
what a badass and then I went he's
wearing no shirt and a meat
Dicky but like badass blue eyed blonde
and haired white kid just
living that'll be a [__] badass gotta
be a badass anyway
um yeah as I was going through the
pictures I'm like yo this is his house
the house he bought when he was 19. and
he sold him remember he was like 20 21
but anyway yeah what are the odds
just leave you with that try to get that
house and I didn't get it but wow
nostalgic purchases
nostalgic Investments that's the name of
my book
nostalgic Investments you see when you
buy a pound for the surprise you just
save and save and save and it reminds me
of high school
nostalgia
guys I'm just rambling I should drink
more water I feel very
supposed to drink like six of those a
day or some [__] I used to have alarms
do you remember that why you should do I
remember I posted my my water alarms or
not vaguely some [__] like that maybe
it's before I don't know damage before I
haven't been drinking water since
I used to put water alarms and I used to
name them hilarious things so I would
laugh and be like they all drink some
water right now because like as they
progressed in the day
it would get at the last one was
Poseidon
my last line was like Poseidon god of
water because I crushed that that day
and then the first one was you thirsty
[__] is the first one of the day and
then every time alarm you thirsty little
[__]
it's just funny to see like I wrote that
funny to me but I don't do the alarms
anymore because we filmed so much yeah
I really need like an Apple watch
drink water I need that we just need
this deal that I proposed the Mountain
Valley to come through so they can just
shout out to Mountain Valley uh until
you get shout out to Mountain Valley
uh water you know I get the glass
bottles the big The Jug five gallon
shout out to delivery driver dropping
one in my driveway today and shattering
glass all over my entire driveway and
then he didn't pick it all up and I
found all the glasses and this happened
while I was on live I saw the truck I'm
like oh truck's here it's like Rob can
you open the garage and he comes in like
this guy just dropped I'm like no he
didn't yeah he did like no he didn't
just drop five gallon glass jug in my
driveway
come on wait was the car in the in the
garage no but John pulled up in his [__]
right after and I was like ah wait you
wait
the guy cleaned it up did a half-assed
job I found chunks this big in my
driveway he was just trying to get out
of there I dropped it
all right I'm out like you [__]
[__] broke it shout's mouth delivery
guy sorry just say that before we leave
I broke that [__] in my driveway today
and as I'm on live like this
[__] and I head to the story time right
after Story time I filmed the Hot Box
video I told Adam get there two o'clock
he got there too my video ended at 2 10.
immediately started filming filming
dropped into here drove straight here
here we are
sometimes I don't have time to drink
water I was just saying like
I have not stopped since
I woke up
so that's why I should get up at six and
stop going to bed at three in the
morning
see now you see my schedule what
happened today very simple things just
had a drop
then I had you know uh uh the HotBox
video lined up right into coming here
we're still here it was pretty tight
he said guys let's get out of here
Mountain Valley shout out to you
drinking your [__] anyway prepares
all right
make a racist fight illegals for
citizenship so terrible all right let's
get out of here Marty thank you so much
for being here I appreciate you guys
thank you so much for being here this
has been another episode of the dope as
usual podcast it has been a very ranty
ranty rambling episode but [__] it it's
fun thank you guys so much for being
here before you got here leave a like
drop a notification subscribe if you're
on Spotify
or if you're not go shine out for
Spotify and follow dope as usual on
there because spotify's putting our
commercials Out There Our Flyers are
helping to put us on the home page shout
out to Spotify for that Step It Up
YouTube appreciate you guys though all
right all right guys thank you so much
for being here I need to go eat food
I'll be starting to get a little
you know girl at a bar that just has too
many shots that's how I feel now like I
should hey like yeah
I'm over here half ass holding my water
oh wobbly I got the shorts on yeah
pretty much a girl at a bar that should
have ate here we go guys I'm out of here
Marty's out here he's got a long drive
thank God sorry all right thank you so
much for being here
um appreciate you guys it's been the
dope as usual podcast where you're here
and we talked about life drugs problems
accomplishments and a whole lot of
[__] in between today have a dope ass
day Mountain Valley pass have a dope ass
day
perfect
[Music]